Insofern, da der Stefan noch einen Tick Zeit hat,
sage ich einfach mal,
wann läuft? Kean, kann ich dir irgendwie
was zu trinken anbieten? Was möchtest du denn gerne?
Sehr gerne. Ja? Sag mal, was du gerne
haben möchtest.
Ich nehme nur zu trinem, wenn du sie mit...
Es ist aber praktisch, dass ich heute extra zwei neue gekauft habe.
Oh, perfekt.
Das war...
Ich habe da letztens so ein schönes Buch.
Entschuldigung, muss mal rausschneiden.
Ich habe da letztens...
Lass dich das nächste Mal irgendwie einen Test machen, bevor du antanzt, mein Freund.
Ich habe, wie gesagt, auf dem Weg eine Fliege verschluckt und es kratzt mir immer noch im Hals.
Die Erkältung ist abgeklungen.
Ich habe letztens so ein schönes Buch gelesen.
Sprache und Sein hieß das, glaube ich.
Und da ging es im allerersten Kapitel gleich mal um ein paar schöne Vergleiche,
wie Sprache dein Denken beeinflusst.
Und da waren so ein paar schöne Sachen dabei,
wie diese klassischen Sachen, die man aus diversen TED-Talks kennt,
Das ist irgendein Stamm,
die keine
relativen Ortsbeschreibungen kennen, sondern nur absolute.
Bei der
krummen Eiche oder sowas?
Nee, im Sinne von Himmelsrichtung.
Da sprichst du nicht von wegen, das ist meine
linke Hand, das ist meine rechte Hand und die wissen halt immer,
dadurch, dass sie es halt... Das ist meine Nordhand und das ist meine Südhand.
Exakt, genau. Warte mal, das ist meine Osthand
und das ist meine Westhand.
Ja, beziehungsweise Nord in dem Fall, genau, ja.
Aber
genau das. Und dadurch, dass sie halt immer
diesen Bezugssystem brauchen, weil sie es halt sprachlich
verankert haben, haben die das halt auch immer
im Kopf. Und das hat auch so witzige
Nebeneffekte. Also zum einen,
abgesehen davon, dass die halt ein sehr interessantes Bild
im Kopf haben, ständig wie sie sich bewegen.
Und so eine Reporterin, die da eine Weile
mit denen gelebt hat, meinte, das ist irgendwas, so ein bisschen,
so eine Art Minimap von der Gegend im Kopf hast,
wo du dich selber positionierst.
Aber das Krasseste fand ich,
dass du, wenn du diese Leute
fragst, also wenn du jetzt eine,
wenn ich dich jetzt frage, ich gebe denen eine Reihe von Bildern in die Hand
und ich frage dich, leg dich doch bitte auf den Tisch
chronologischer Reihenfolge, dann wirst du höchstwahrscheinlich
die Bilder von links nach rechts sortieren
zeitlich aufsteigend, dass halt links das
älteste ist und rechts das neueste.
Weil es einfach am normalsten.
Weil wir auch von links nach rechts lesen.
Da gibt es so einen Test, wo du so ein Crescendo malst
und da fragst du den, wird das größer oder wird das kleiner?
Sehr schön. Aber diese Menschen
von diesem Stamm, wenn du die zeitlich was sortieren lässt,
dann spielt es halt eine Rolle,
wie rum die am Tisch sitzen, weil für die
fließt die Zeit von Westen nach Osten.
Und das ist halt auch so ein Ding, wo du
Wie krass, wie kann das halt so tief
in dir verankert sein?
Aber die Sorte geht doch im Osten auf.
Hey Stefan, sag mal bitte was.
Stefan ist da?
Stefan ist da.
Hi Kilian.
Hi Henrik.
Hi Stefan.
Hi.
Das war wohl der Schild.
Ich sollte einen Namen sagen.
Ach Quatsch, nee.
Super, perfekt.
Auf jeden Fall. Ich muss auch gerade sagen,
ich hätte mich jetzt vorgestellt, ich hätte jetzt einfach gesagt,
hi, hier ist der Stefan, ich weiß gar nicht, dein Nachnamen
gar nicht, vielleicht... Schindler.
Schindler. Schindler, ja.
Wir haben einen Gast dieses Mal dabei,
den Stefan, und wenn er genau
inhört, so ein bisschen auf die Inflexion,
wenn er redet, ihr habt ihn in diesem Podcast
auch schon mal gehört, denn er war vor
zwei oder drei Folgen bereits zu Besuch, als wir
über Konferenzen,
Organisationen in der
Pandemie geredet haben, und das
muss ich sagen, war eine sehr, sehr schöne Folge.
und da dachten wir, wir müssen uns nochmal unterhalten.
War das im Dezember die Folge?
Das war unsere
Kongress-Folge.
Das Holiday-Special.
Ah, das Holiday-Special war das.
Wenn ihr die Folge nicht gehört habt,
hört euch definitiv nochmal unser Holiday-Special an.
Mit den Organisatoren des Rust-Fests.
Florian, Stefan und
Jan-Erik.
Genau.
Und Stefan, du bist
neben der Tatsache, dass du
Mitorganisator des Rust-Fests bist,
oder MC oder Moderator
letzten Rust-Fests oder der
letzten Rust-Fests warst?
Rust-Feste.
Rust-Feste? Rust-Feste.
Rust-Feste. Ich glaube, auf Deutsch
hat es ein E dann. Rust-Fest-Handen.
Rust-Fest-Handen.
Betreibst du auch
ein Meetup
oder ein lokales
Rust-Treffen
in Zürich?
Richtig? Ja, genau.
Wir haben damals
gingen wir zu dritt
von Zürich nach Berlin ans erste
Rustfest und waren so
voll die
Sprache, voll die netten Leute
und dann
Das waren voll die netten Leute
Ich habe da den Jupp kennengelernt
aus dem Rustfest
Dann sind es ja per Definition
voll die netten Leute
Ja, dann habe ich
gesagt, ja ich würde das gerne in Zürich
machen und sie so
und dann, ja, wann soll denn das nächste
so steigen? So, ja, in einem halben Jahr.
Ich dachte, nein, nein, das geht nicht,
das ist zu nah. Ich habe gesagt, ich brauche mindestens
ein Jahr und dann
Leute finden, die mitmachen.
Und
dann kam am Ende
der Konferenz die Überraschung.
Es gab dann Kiew.
Es gab bereits eine Planung für den nächsten Nachfolger.
Ah, okay. Genau.
Es wusste niemand außer die Orga
und dann gab es
Also die Überraschung hier ist Rustfest Kiew in sechs Monaten, war das glaube ich, fünf oder sechs Monate danach.
Und dann habe ich in der Zwischenzeit Leute gesucht, die das mitorganisieren wollten und auch ein paar gefunden.
Und dann ging das über mehrere Iterationen durch, haben wir uns da Orte angeschaut und irgendwann bei der Uni sind wir fündig geworden und haben dann gesagt, ja, okay, wir müssen schon einen Verein gründen.
Und es wäre doch super, wenn wir
auf das Rust-Fest hin
schon Meetups organisieren.
Und dann haben Sebastian und ich den
Verein gegründet.
Achso, den Verein habt ihr für das Rust-Fest gegründet.
Genau, also wir haben
gesagt, wir wollen den nicht nur für das Rust-Fest,
sondern wir wollen den einfach für Rust
Schweiz, Rust Zürich haben.
Und haben dann
ein paar Meetups organisiert,
dann die Konferenz und dann haben wir gesagt,
achso, das geht ja ganz gut, wir machen
jetzt einfach weiter mit den Meetups.
Voll gut.
das Lustige war
wir hatten das Datum
das ging ein paar Mal ein bisschen vor und zurück
das war dann ein Septemberdatum
fast ein Jahr später
das fiel dann
zusammen mit der Hochzeit
von einem guten Freund von mir
und damit war das halbe
Orga-Team bei der Hochzeit
Nein
Scheiße
Und die hatten das Datum nach
der Konferenz bekannt gegeben.
Das ist ja auch cool.
Ja, aber so eine Hochzeit trumpft immer.
Das ist das Problem.
Und dann war ich nicht
nah genug dran und habe dann gesagt,
ja, ich wurde nicht eingeladen zur Hochzeit.
Dann kann ich die Konferenz machen.
Achso, dann hast du das alleine geschmissen?
Nein, ich habe dann,
also Sebastian war auch nicht eingeladen
bei der Konferenz und wir haben noch
Vazia gefunden,
die Arbeitskollegen. Also Sebastian und Vazia
waren damals beide Doktorantinnen
bei der ETH und ich war
wissenschaftlicher Mitarbeiter.
Ja, und da hatten wir
guten Zugang auf
Räume und
Plätze. Und was
auch nicht zu unterschätzen war,
es gab damals ein bisschen
kooperative Konkurrenz.
Und zwar mit dem
C++ Meetup.
Weil drei
gute Freunde von mir haben das
C++ Meetup organisiert.
ist bestimmt kein Ovalab.
Wie ist denn das?
Achso, red erst mal weiter.
Ja, also das C++ Meetup
kam halt aus der Ecke raus.
Ja, maximale Performance,
ultrazentrale
Dienste von Firmen.
Also wenn du in der Schweiz eine Firma
hast und die setzt C++
ein produktiv, dann ist das
im Core-System drin
von dem Geschäft.
Es gibt ja auch ein relativ wichtiges
internationales C++-Treffen
in der Schweiz.
Wie hieß es?
Rapperswil.
Da war mir immer gar nicht klar, dass das in der Schweiz ist.
Ja, Rapperswil,
das könnte sich aber jetzt
ändern, weil der Professor,
der uns an C++,
fast an C++ beigebracht hat,
der hat in Rapperswil
unterrichtet, wo ich studiert habe.
Ah, deshalb.
Den kannte ich.
Den Sommerlad.
Krass. Und wie war
das Verhältnis zwischen dem
C++-Meetup und dem Rust-Meetup
dann in Zürich?
Eigentlich sehr gut.
Es gab auch
relativ viele Überschneidungen wahrscheinlich, oder?
Es gab ein bisschen
Konkurrenz, ja, und Rust war noch
nicht so weit. Also Cerde
war damals noch nicht so weit,
dass es mit Strömen umgehen konnte.
Sondern man hat dann halt
Puffer serialisiert.
Was ist denn damals, von welchem Zeitpunkt
hier? Wahrscheinlich
2016,
17.
16, 17, ja.
Weißt du doch, als Serre noch keine
Streams konnte. Ja, klar kann ich natürlich
sofort genau einordnen, wann das
war. 2016, als es Serre
noch nicht gab. Das war so das Jahr
2, 3
before Corona, BC.
Aha, before Corona.
Ich frage ja auch so ein bisschen aus der Ecke,
also meine eigene Geschichte ist, dass ich irgendwie kurz
bisschen in Rust reingekommen bin und mir dann irgendwie
übers Rustfest auch gedacht habe, ach weißt du, so ein Meetup
könntest du eigentlich in Dresden auch mal machen.
Aber bei mir hat es irgendwie nie so richtig abgehoben.
Also ich hatte die
größte Attendance
hatte ich, wenn ich das Meetup direkt
bei uns in der Uni gemacht habe und quasi
die paar Nerds, die eh schon den ganzen Tag um mich drum rum
saßen, dann einfach da geblieben sind und dann haben wir
zusammen uns mal Rocket angeschaut
oder so. Ah, da war ich auch dabei, das war witzig.
Genau, aber
es hat häufig einfach nicht gut
funktioniert, dass das irgendwie, ich habe es richtig auf Meetup
gekündigt und
ein paar Mal hat es geklappt, dass irgendwie
fünf Leute gekommen sind.
In der Slup waren auch damals eine ganze Reihe Leute da, oder?
In der Slup waren manchmal drei, vier Leute da, genau.
Aber es war immer relativ klein, deswegen frage ich mich,
wie groß waren eigentlich eure Meetups in Zürich?
Wir haben uns ein bisschen
gegenseitig befruchtet, alle Meetups.
Also das kann man schon sagen.
Weil
es hast es leichter, wenn du schon
bei einem großen Meetup vorbeischneidst und
sagst, ach ja, ich mache ein eigenes, klar.
Das ist natürlich eine gute Idee, das habe ich nie gemacht.
Ja, wir haben
da gut profitiert von
ich glaube das
Python-Meetup war das erste
größere.
Ist das der Grund, warum jetzt in Python
selbst viel mehr Rust sich immer weiter reinfindet?
Und die ganze Python
ist das sich, also wirklich?
Also wenn du
schaust, woher die Leute kommen, was so ihre
vorherigen Sprachen waren,
sehr viele sagen
Python, Ruby,
JavaScript oder PHP.
Und dann gibt es noch den
anderen Typus, der kriegt halt
C.
Die Leute, die C machen und C schon können,
sind meistens über diesen,
die haben meistens diesen Survivor-Bias schon
und sagen sich,
der C ist doch nicht schwer.
Oder C++, ich bin super produktiv,
C++ ist performant, es ist auch sicher.
Also wenn ich es schreibe, ist es sicher.
Und da brauche ich mir doch nicht so eine neue Sprache
reinziehen.
Der Survivorische Bias trifft dir echt gut.
Das ist schön.
Genau, und dann gibt es aber zwei super Argumente.
Und das eine
ist Serde.
Wirklich.
Es ist so schwer,
in C-Datenstrukturen korrekt auf einen
Socket zu drücken und wieder rauszuholen.
Definitiv, ja. Serde ist auch ein Game Changer.
Und das andere ist
wirklich der Compiler.
Also ich habe, ich muss mich erinnern,
Das war die Woche vor der Konferenz, hatten wir noch ein Meetup, da ist Professor Sommerlad gekommen.
Übrigens, das war ein Standardmitglied, also von diesem C++-Standardgremium war er ein Mitglied.
Und der war dann bei unserem Vortrag, und es ging um Dokumentation, wenn ich mich recht erinnere.
Und es ging eigentlich nur darum, wie du mit diesen Dreifach-Schrägstrichen vor der Funktion, vor der Struktur,
im Anfang vom Modul, genau, die ganzen Dokuments.
und das hat ihn schon ziemlich beeindruckt
und dann haben wir auch drin gezeigt,
ja, du kannst halt ausführbare Codebeispiele haben
und wenn die nicht kompilieren,
dann kommt die schöne Fehlermeldung.
Und diese Art Fehlermeldung ist jetzt in Clang drin
und ich glaube, das hat da ein bisschen den Weg gefunden.
Ich sage nicht, dass er es implementiert hat,
aber einfach so zu zeigen,
hey, schaut euch diese Fehlermeldung an.
Das ist cool.
Wenn ich Triple-Zeichen höre, denke ich immer an
Trigramme. Das ist wahrscheinlich das coolste
Feature, was auch bei den meisten C-Compilern
funktioniert, wo du durch...
Was war das, dass du, wenn du bestimmte
Sonderzeichen nicht tippen kannst, war glaube ich die
Grundidee auf deiner Tastatur, dann kannst du
die halt auch anders ausdrücken durch
eine Zeichenfolge von drei anderen Zeichen.
Und irgendwas war halt,
irgendeine Zeichenfolge gab es, dass du halt
einen Zeilenumbruch und einen Doppelslash
direkt ausdrücken kannst.
Wenn du das halt an dein Zeilenende ranpackst, meinetwegen in einem Kommentar,
dann kommentierst du halt implizit die nächste Zeile
aus, aber das siehst du halt nicht im Editor.
Das macht der Compiler halt einfach mit.
Das ist so ein
wunderschönes Easter Egg, was man in Code versteckt.
Das heißt, du kannst da Code haben,
wo du schreibst einen Kommentar drüber
und die nächste Zeile ist aber eigentlich
auskommentiert, aber du siehst es nicht direkt.
Die ist halt für den Compiler auskommentiert, aber nicht für dich.
Wenn du Pech hast, für den Code-Highlighter
auch nicht und du denkst die...
Ja genau, der Code-Highlighter hat wahrscheinlich keine Ahnung davon,
dass das das Trigramm ein Ding sind.
Ach du Scheiße.
Da fällt mir gerade ein, das war eins von den besten C++ Meetups in der Zeit.
Da ging es auch um die Trigramme und die haben erklärt, warum die die gebraucht haben.
Das war für den Mainframe.
Ah, okay.
Die Kodierung von C-Code war ja Ansied.
Genau.
Also das ist die 7-Bit-Geschichte.
Und für den Mainframe brauchten sie aber diese IBM-Kodierung.
Und da brauchst du gewisse Zeichen halt und da brauchst du diese Trigramme.
Dinge, über die man sich heute
um Gottes Willen, Gott sei Dank, keine Gedanken
mehr machen muss. Stell dir vor, du müsstest
Puny Code in deiner Programmiersprache
schreiben oder sowas.
Letztens hatte ich irgendeinen Use Case
dafür gehabt, meine Variablen mit
Emojis zu benennen. Ich komme gerade nicht mehr
drauf. Aber es fühlte sich tatsächlich sinnvoll an.
Welches Emoji war es?
Ach, das waren glaube ich Länderflaggen.
Die habe ich für Identifier missbraucht
gehabt. Also für
Sprachidentifier. Aber das fand ich
an der Stelle ganz schick sogar, weil es halt
optisch schöner war. Aber natürlich
ist es so ein Ding, wenn jemand mit einem Editor
herkommt, der das nicht wendern kann, dann
sorry, das ist halt scheiße. Oder wenn
das Betriebssystem von der Person dieses
Emoji noch nicht hat. Aber es gibt kein, achso,
das spielt ja keine Rolle. Ja, aber
dann sieht es kacke aus.
Das stimmt. Aber die Sprachflaggen
sind ja alle schon ganz am Anfang mit drin gewesen.
Also dann gibt es kein Betriebssystem, was
den Swift-Compiler,
wo der Swift-Compiler drauf läuft, du aber dann
darüber stolperst, dass das Unicode-Dateien sind.
Äh, ich kreuz mal meine Finger, keine Ahnung
Dafür läuft Swift nicht auf genug System
Swift läuft doch jetzt
mittlerweile auf
Na ja, gut, okay, wahrscheinlich
modernem Linux zumindest
Gab's da nicht mal so diese Switches, die irgendwie
Deep Package Inspection gemacht haben
und dann bei UTF-8-Strings umgefallen sind
Ach geil
Blackboxen
Und die Lösung war dann TLS
Oh schön
Herrlicher Workaround
super clever. Achso, du machst quasi
das Deep Packet Inspection aus,
auf die Art. Indem du verschlüsselst.
Ja, das ist doch mal ein Grund,
wenn du nicht verschlüsselst, geht ständig mein Netzwerk aus.
Verstehe ich nicht.
Ja, also zumindest
Meetups müssen sich also irgendwie
in der Stadt oder vor Ort
so gegenseitig befruchten, hast du gemeint.
Dann funktioniert das einigermaßen gut, wenn man ein bisschen Werbung macht auf seinem
und dann zu dem nächsten
auf einem anderen ein bisschen Werbung
so ein bisschen sein eigenes Meetup plackt.
Genau, also das ist sicher das eine
du kannst bei anderen vorbeischauen
und dann
Leute, die sich schon
ehemal dafür interessiert haben
darauf hinweisen, dass es das gibt
was wir auch
sehr früh angefangen haben
damals ehrlicherweise um die
Technik zu testen, mit der wir dann
Rustfest aufgenommen haben, waren halt Aufnahmen
und die Aufnahmen waren
zum Teil richtig schlecht
aber wir haben viel gelernt und es gab
Aufnahmen. Also das muss man auch sagen.
Das war am Anfang.
Also 2017
ein Meetup, das Videoaufnahmen
hat, das war selten.
Also ich glaube Berlin hatte das
vor uns und sonst
eigentlich nur die Konferenzen.
Aber so ein normales Meetup,
es gab keine Aufnahmen.
In Dresden gibt es schon seit einigen Jahren die
C++ User Group, wo wir gerade so viel über C++ reden.
Und der Organisator davon
ist auch eigentlich sehr gut organisiert.
der war auch einer der häufigsten Besucher meines Rust-Meetups.
Ist das Andreas?
Andreas, genau.
Und dem ist es auch wichtig, dass jedes Meetup aufgezeichnet wird.
Aber der hat auch tatsächlich Redner.
Der hat auch tatsächlich irgendwie jedes Mal jemanden, der was erzählt.
Und das geht auch ganz gut.
Bei meinen Meetups, das war ja so ein Hack-and-Learn
und wir treffen uns gemeinsam und reden mal über irgendwas.
Und dann habe ich meistens nicht die ganze Zeit geredet,
weil die Leute immer bloß zu einmal kamen.
Das nimmt sich natürlich auch schwieriger auf, klar.
Ja, wäre natürlich trotzdem ein schöner Mehrwert dafür.
Ich habe immer mal Leute gebeten, Mensch,
red doch mal über ein Thema hier.
Leute, die jetzt nicht beim... Nein, nein, du machst doch was Cooles damit.
Nein, trau mich nicht.
Das macht man da, wenn jemand sagt, trau ich mich nicht.
Pech, hier ist eine Kamera.
Nee, das ist schwierig.
Kann man nicht zwingen, ne?
Also, zwingen nicht. Nein, zwingen auf keinen Fall.
Nein, du kannst die Leute bestechen.
Auf diverse Arten.
Wie besticht man die Leute? Erzähl mir mehr.
Das einfachste ist Geld.
Das ist ja langweilig.
Da braucht man aber Sponsoren.
Das ist langweilig.
Und sonst muss man auch kreativ werden.
Also vielleicht kannst du den Leuten etwas bieten,
was sie brauchen.
Und dann sagst du, hey, ich erzähle dir das.
Und vielleicht machst du dann irgendwann mal freiwillig einen Vortrag.
Vielleicht könnte man sich...
Also das soll jetzt keine Anleitung zum Mobbing werden.
An der Stelle.
Vielleicht könnte man sich mit dem Rust-Core-Team
ein bisschen einschmeicheln und
den Leuten, die die Vorträge halten,
die den Nightly einen Tag früher zukommen lassen,
die nächste.
Die Nightly?
Das war die vom Vortag, aber...
Das ist die Yesterdayly.
Oh Mann, die Tomorrowly.
Tomorrowly-Symptom, ja.
Die Tomorrowly mit dem Code aus der Zukunft.
Oh, Import from Future,
wenn wir wieder bei Python werden.
Oh Mann, Python.
Und wie läuft der Meetup
zu Zeiten von Pandemie, wo man sich nicht
vor Ort treffen kann?
Ja, damit fällt eigentlich die dritte Art weg.
Also wir hatten so einen Rhythmus dann gefunden, das ging immer damit los.
Das erste war Rust Introduction.
Wir haben drei bis viermal im Jahr einfach Einführungen in Rust gegeben.
Das war eine halbe Stunde, drei Viertel Vortrag.
Das war am Anfang ein zwei Stunden Vortrag.
Und dann haben wir das sehr stark reduziert,
weil zwei Stunden Spracheinführung, das tötet die Leute.
Ja, da bist du auch hinterher im Arsch.
Ich habe bei uns auf Arbeit diesen Gentle Introduction to Rust,
von den Rustbridge-Leuten diesen Vortrag mal gemacht,
noch ein bisschen angepasst für C++-Entwickler.
Aber da war auch hinterher nicht mehr viel aus den Leuten rauszuholen,
wenn ich da mit dem ersten Programm durchfahre.
Und das war nicht, also für mein Verständnis,
nicht viel, aber wenn das alles komplett neues,
abstraktes Sprachwissen für dich ist,
bist du hinterher ausgepowert.
Ja, was wir gemerkt haben, ist,
du darfst gar nicht so genau werden.
Wenn du dich auskennst, ist gut,
aber im Vortrag drin,
du brauchst
keine Grammatik
von der Sprache,
die dir das interessiert,
die fragen danach,
du musst das Enum
nicht zweimal erklären.
Also, du kannst einmal sagen,
so schauen, das ist
ein Resultat,
das hat zwei generische Parameter,
das ist ein Elim, da können wir Daten mitschicken
und dann musst du
Option nicht mehr durcharbeiten,
also absolut, und hier ist Option,
das ersetzt uns die Null-Pointer.
Ein Satz, keine Folie,
oder vielleicht eine kurze Folie,
aber ein Satz.
Solche Dinge hatten wir halt am Anfang,
das war dann umgekehrt, man hat gesagt,
zuerst mal den Enum und die Syntax
und dann bauen wir alle Dinge ein
da ist es nur so, was passiert?
Und dann jetzt noch generische Parameter,
was ist los? Und dann hier ist
ein Option und alles so, aha.
Insofern ist das
diese Bridge-Vorträge,
also zumindest Rust-Bridge,
das ist ja quasi
so an Ruby-Bridge angelehnt,
die sind eigentlich
schön semantisch aufgebaut und so ein bisschen motiviert.
Also wichtig ist bei solchen Sachen, dass du motivierst.
Warum haben wir sowas?
Das hat mich immer gestimmt bei den Programmierkursen,
bei uns in der Uni. Also ihr habt wahrscheinlich in Zürich
dann mit
Rapperswillen
oder ihr habt wahrscheinlich da eine bessere
Tradition, aber wenn ich mich so erinnere,
Programmierkurs C
in der Uni bei uns. Die ersten
zehn Folien waren nur Syntax, dann
ging es irgendwie, war eine Extrafolie nur mit
Datentypen. Das ist halt so ein Ding, wenn du halt
nicht weißt, wie man sowas gut rüberbringt,
dann ist das genau die Herangehensweise, wie du es machst.
Klar, ich packe hier zehn Folien erstmal, ich erkläre die Syntax
weiter. Genau.
Das lernt sich natürlich
gut. Das merkst du aber erst, nachdem du das
drei Kurse beigebracht hast.
Ja, aber dann hast du halt auch schon drei Kurse
irgendwie so
verbrannt.
Und es gibt
Leute, die merken das nicht, dass sie das falsch machen,
wenn sie dir was beibringen. Die Folien,
auf denen sie dann aufbauen, sind ja manchmal schon
zehn Jahre alt und die funktionieren immer noch.
Klar, Lehren muss halt auch gelernt
werden. Das ist halt nicht selbstverständlich.
Auf jeden Fall.
Für vierte mehr kommen.
Also an den Unis fällt dieser Satz
Atelier muss gelernt werden.
Ich bin ja studierter
Medieninformatiker. Ich bin
auch selbstbewusst, das laut auszusprechen.
Ich habe auch mit studiert.
Wir hatten
eine Lehrveranstaltung,
die hieß Mediendidaktik.
Da ging es wirklich um Didaktik.
Und das war die langweiligste
und am schlechtesten herausgearbeitete
Vorlesung, die ich je gehört habe.
Das ist echt wahr.
Du denkst ja so,
Warte mal, ist das jetzt ja gerade irgendwie Erklären am Gegenbeispiel?
Ich erinnere mich nicht an,
das einzige, woran ich mich an dieses Modul noch erinnere,
war dieses Lernspiel, was wir entwickeln sollten.
Da sollten wir halt in einer kleinen Gruppe ein Spiel entwickeln,
wo man irgendwas, komplett random,
was aber irgendwas bei nicht gelernt hat.
Das war halt ein witziges Gruppenprojekt,
aber an Inhalte aus dem Modul erinnere ich mich überhaupt nicht.
Nee, eigentlich war es total sinnlos.
Da wurden mal andere Lernsoftwaren erklärt
oder da wurde irgendwie mal erklärt,
wie man einen
Automaten,
einen Fahrkartenautomaten
so macht, dass die Leute ihn, wenn sie das erste Mal
benutzen, verstehen.
Egal. Also Programmieren lernen
oder Programmieren vermitteln,
egal in welchem Kontext, ist
eigentlich immer, es geht eigentlich nie.
Es ist eigentlich immer scheiße.
Ist das vielleicht so der Grund, warum wir so ein
Nachwuchsproblem haben in der
Softwarewelt?
Eigentlich habe ich den Eindruck, die Leute, die Programmierer
werden oder Softwareentwickler werden, sind die,
die es selber lernen wollten.
Oder? Es gibt doch relativ wenige
wahrscheinlich, die gesagt haben,
ich gehe da jetzt hin und
dann alles, was ich irgendwie in meiner
Lehrveranstaltung gelernt habe, reicht völlig aus,
um mich für den Beruf zu qualifizieren.
Oder?
Also ich habe das Gefühl,
dass viele Leute, die
irgendwie in diese Rolle reinrutschen,
du musst jetzt das Programmieren unterrichten,
die denken sich so, aha,
ja, das ist deine Sprache,
was war die schwerste Sprache, die ich jemals selber gelernt habe?
Und dann, ach ja, Französisch.
Und was tun wir dann?
Ja, wir erschlagen die Leute zuerst mal mit Grammatik und Vokabeln.
Nee, genau.
Und das ist genau das, was viele machen.
Hier ist die Grammatik, die Syntax.
Und die Vokabeln sind dann halt so Dinge wie,
und eine Funktion machst du mit Fn oder mit Function.
Eine normale Sprache, so geht man das ja nicht an, auch im Kindheitsalter.
Das ist ja totaler Quatsch eigentlich.
Genau.
Du hast deutsche Grammatik in der Schule beigebracht bekommen.
Wie viel weißt du davon noch?
Ja, aber Jahre nach, also abgesehen davon, dass ich nichts mehr zu, also ich weiß, was im Deutschen falsch klingt.
Warum kriegt man eigentlich als Kind in der dritten Klasse den Akkusativ erklärt?
Es bringt halt absolut, ich meine, bis zu Zeit.
Es ist eigentlich Zeitverschwendung, oder?
Du weißt halt, also du kannst halt schon Deutsch zu dem Zeitpunkt.
Ich meine, du bist natürlich kein Profi.
Genau, was ist da der Sinn, dass ich da Meta, das ist auch die schwerste Sprache, ich weiß nicht, wie es in der Schweiz ist,
Französischunterricht bei uns,
boah, fürchterlich. Das war eigentlich nur
Grammatik und Vokabellern. Kein Mensch hat dabei
diese Sprache gelernt. Warum wird das so falsch gemacht?
Ich muss sagen, unser Spanischlehrer hat das tatsächlich besser
gemacht. Da haben wir wirklich sehr
auf
Konversationsebene
hat er das versucht, uns näher zu bringen. Genau, also sobald du
sprichst, da hast du ja plötzlich einen besseren Bezug dazu.
Genau, wir haben überhaupt nichts mit Grammatik
uns angeschaut. Natürlich ein bisschen später,
da brauchte man irgendwelche Zeitformen mit anzusprechen,
aber es ging wirklich erstmal hier ein paar Grundvokabeln
und dann haben wir versucht, daraus irgendwie uns zu
unterhalten und immer mehr ein paar mehr Vokabeln
mit eingeworfen.
Ja, genau. Und ich merke irgendwie,
wenn jemand jemand anders Programmieren
beibringt, dann fangen viele damit an.
Das ist ein if, das ist ein for.
Das ist ein...
Es gibt Strings
und es gibt Integer
und es gibt Double und es gibt
Longs und es gibt
Double Longs.
Warum alle Zahlentypen erstmal auflisten?
Das brauchst du erstmal gar nicht.
Ja, und dann kommt das Objekt und dann sind alle so, was ist ein Objekt?
Ja, und dann kommt das Taschenrechner-Beispiel.
Jedes Mal.
Das ist Standard-Java-Vorlesung.
Wir machen jetzt ein Taschenrechner-Objekt, das hat verschiedene Operatoren und so drauf.
Und dann kommt die Frage aus der dritten Reihe.
Moment.
Was?
Ist eine Zahl kein Objekt?
Oh krass.
Und dann bist du schon wieder so.
Aber wenn so eine Frage kommt, dann sind die Leute ja tatsächlich so ein bisschen in der Thematik drin.
Ich hatte fünf Jahre...
Ja, aber wie reagierst du auf die Frage?
Ja, es ist natürlich schwierig.
Du willst ja nicht zu weit dann absteigen
und den Leuten unterschiedlich zwischen diversen Sprachen
und wie damit umgehen, mit erläutern.
Aber du willst ja auch die Frage irgendwie beantworten.
Ich hatte fünf Jahre an der Uni Maschinenbaustudenten
im zweiten Semester C-Sharp-Entwicklung.
CIS-Entwicklung, sorry.
CIS heißt die Sprache.
CIS heißt so CIS.
Versucht beizubringen.
Ich versuchte, es hat auch meistens ganz gut geklappt.
Aber genau das, was du halt meinst.
Man hat halt so ein paar Grundkonzepte erstmal mit reingebracht
und dann, sobald es halt das Thema Objektorientierung aufkam
und man versucht hat, den Unterschied zwischen Klassen und Objekten,
also manche haben es relativ schnell verstanden,
für manche war das halt das Mysterium schlechthin bis zum Ende des Semesters
und wenn du halt versuchst, so, keine Ahnung,
anhand von einem Auto, war ja mein Go-To-Beispiel,
dass du halt den Blueprint hast in der Fabrik,
den Bauplan und ganz viele Autos,
dass du halt versuchst, sich daran zu handeln,
aber das war halt ein Thema, was bei manchen,
Das ging einfach nicht. Das war komplex,
wenn du da halt nicht ein bisschen Grundwissen hast
oder was mitbringst.
Und das Grundwissen,
das kommt ja nicht, weil du
irgendwas gelernt hast, sondern weil
du irgendwie zufällig
das Glück hattest, dass jemand dir das
irgendwie so im Vorbeigehen erzählt
hat. Vielleicht, weil du, keine Ahnung,
irgendein Spielzeug programmiert hast.
Genau, du möchtest was bauen.
Du möchtest eigentlich, die Leute, die anfangen zu programmieren,
die haben bereits irgendwie vor Augen, ich möchte
was machen. Ich hatte einen Schulfreund, der
hatte so ein geiles Top-Down-Star-Wars-Spiel
gebaut, wo der so ein 2D-Space
dich mit
Galaxy-Class
gegen Dominion-Schiff irgendwie
abgeschossen hat. Das fand ich total geil, wollte ich auch
irgendwann bauen. Und dann hat er gesagt, na klar,
ich hab ein C++ gemacht, hier, guck mal.
Und dann war es für mich vorbei. Aber
du musst halt irgendwie ein Ziel vor Augen
haben. Also brauchst du irgendwie nicht das Abstrakte.
Und dann denke ich mir, wenn du dir jemanden programmierend
von vorne beibringst, aber jetzt sind wir schon von
hundertstens tausendste gekommen,
da muss man auch nicht mit C anfangen, weil das die
gut gelegenste Sprache ist.
Bitte nicht.
Sondern, vor allem wenn du halt versuchst,
Pointer zu erklären.
Genau, also
hasst mich, aber wenn ich jemandem, wenn ich
irgendwie
einem Kind programmieren von 0 auf jetzt beibringen
würde, würde ich sagen, hier guck dir mal
JavaScript an.
Damit kriegst du fast alles abgebildet
und du kannst es, du musst einfach
hier bloß deinen Browser aufmachen, dann drückst du F12
und dann kannst du bereits anfangen zu tippen.
Die On-Ramp ist sehr easy, auf jeden Fall.
Und du kannst halt auch
Ich hab meine Schwester von Python beigebracht.
Entschuldigung.
Das ist auch eine super Wahl. Ich hab auch gerade überlegt, was so eine gute
Einstiegssprache wäre. Ich hätte auch wahrscheinlich so Python tendiert,
aber wie Hendrik schon meint, dadurch, dass
JavaScript halt schon überall läuft,
also literally auf jedem Gerät, was ich
besitze, kann ich JavaScript
ausführen, relativ problemlos.
Ich glaub, auf der Uhr wird's ein bisschen schwierig, aber
prinzipiell
geht's halt erstmal hier tippen können.
Ich hatte mal eine Uhr mit JavaScript,
die Pebble.
Ja, die hat
C++-Firmware und die Widgets,
wie sie die Apps nannten, waren alle
JavaScript.
Das ist toll, das schönste Weiß.
Wir haben gerade eine Referenz zurück zu unserer
vorherigen Folge.
Ich wechsle gerade meinen Arbeitgeber
und mein neuer
Chef ist der Gründer der Pebble.
Dem leite ich deine Begeisterung doch direkt weiter.
dass ich noch mehr Referenzen in the Wild getroffen habe.
Hauptsache, er bringt die Uhr zurück.
Ne, wo waren wir und stehen geblieben?
Ja, was macht es so schwer,
gut Leute ins Programmieren reinzubringen?
Ich glaube, du hast das vorhin gesagt,
das ist wirklich das Problemlösen.
Wenn du die Leute anschaust,
die vor dem Studium schon programmieren konnten,
dann ist es so dieser Bastler-Typ.
Oder Spieler, die sich eigenes Spielbau holen.
Ja, genau. Entweder hast du digital gebastelt
oder halt in der physischen Welt mit
ferngestalteten Modellen oder irgend sowas.
Und die sind
das erste Jahr massiv
überlegen, weil sie diesen Frust nicht
haben von den Programmiervorlesungen.
Genau, das sind die, die sich langweilen.
Genau. Aber es ist nicht mit jedem
Thema so. Ich meine, du hast ja,
ich könnte mir jetzt 20 Bücher zum Tischlern
durchlesen, aber wirklich,
das können werde ich nicht, bevor
ich mir wirklich einen Tisch zusammenschreide.
Also, weil ich halt nicht die Problemlösung wirklich, also ich versuche nicht ein echtes Problem damit zu lösen.
Und wenn ich mir halt zweimal Java als eine Insel durchlese, dann werde ich wahrscheinlich genauso wenig entwickeln können,
wie wenn ich wirklich mal versuche, was mit Java zu basteln.
Ja, ja.
Das ist mir als dickes Mal gerade eingefallen.
Und ein Jahr später, wenn alle Studenten dann brav ihre Projekte gemacht haben, dann siehst du plötzlich fast keinen Unterschied mehr.
Genau, dann ist das irgendwie einigermaßen vorbei, weil dann haben dann die Nerds, die bereits so hingekommen sind, häufig ihren Vorteil nicht mehr.
Das ist auch das Schöne am Software entwickeln. Du musst nicht wirklich tief einsteigen und viele Grundprinzipien verstanden haben, bis es irgendwie Klick macht und du halt den Rest wirklich sehr autodidaktisch und vor allem schnell und effizient erlernen kannst.
Natürlich gibt es wieder ein paar gewisse Hürden
bei bestimmten Thematiken und so weiter,
aber wenn du einmal so ein kleines Projekt gemacht hast,
dann tust du dich auf jeden Fall sehr viel einfacher,
nach dieser ersten Hürde weiterzukommen,
als wie es davor wirkt.
Und erst mal die Rollreibung überwinden.
Ja, genau das.
Die Rollreibung überwinden, dann läuft das.
Und du bist dann zu diesem geschützten Gefäß
von irgendeiner gemanagten Sprache,
irgendein Stavascript oder Python?
Was ist das Beispiel?
Bei Rust kommst du schon aus diesem
Töpfchen raus.
Also bei Rust hast du
die Möglichkeit.
Bei Rust hast du direkt den Pair-Programmer
dazu, der Compiler, der dir erklärt,
was du falsch machst und dabei freundlich bleibt.
Ja, bei Rust muss er auch ein bisschen mehr...
Ja, ich glaube, das ist wirklich viel wert.
Auf jeden Fall.
Das haben wir gemacht. Wir haben diese
Introductions dann runtergekürzt
auf 45, 50 Minuten
und dann gesagt, okay,
wir bauen jetzt eine Serie.
Ja.
So, das heißt, ihr habt quasi
eine Kadenz gehabt,
wo ihr einmal
so eine Intro gemacht habt und dann das nächste Mal
war ein Vortrag und dann das nächste Mal
war so ein Hacktogether oder sowas quasi.
Nicht ganz, wir haben
das Intro gemacht,
45, 50 Minuten
zu den Highlights von Rust
und dann auch schon so
hey, das ist Cargo,
Hier kannst du mit der Cargo-Tommel Dinge hinzufügen.
Und dann haben wir das so ein bisschen gelenkt.
Und zwar haben wir gesagt, ja gut, den zweiten Teil,
es gab dann wirklich eine kurze Pause dazwischen,
machen wir uns eine kleine CLE-App.
Also da hatten die Leute sich dann ein kleines Comment-Line-Ding gebaut.
Das eine war einfach Argumente rausholen aus dem Standard-Enf.
Und das andere war, glaube ich, ein kleiner Rechner.
Und dann haben wir gesagt, das sind die zwei Beispiele,
wenn du schon programmieren kannst, dann erledigst du das wahrscheinlich in zehn Minuten.
Und dann hätten wir hier ein paar Vorschläge.
Oder du kannst dann einfach fragen.
Und die meisten Leute waren dann so,
ich habe dir das ja vorhin gezeigt, wo du Dokumentation findest.
Und dann haben sich viele irgendwas mit HashMap zusammengebaut
und sich dann selber vertieft.
Und die, die noch keine große Erfahrung hatten,
die waren dann so, aha, okay,
Ich will das nicht auf meinem Rechner installieren,
weil ich das nicht warten will
oder kann oder keinen Platz habe.
Da steht ja Curl in dem Aufruf, genau.
Ja, ja.
Viele Leute, die nicht
professionell in der Informatik sind, haben
keinen Speicherplatz frei.
Was ich meine, so 50 Megabyte
und weniger. Echt, was?
Ja, also so wenig
das Windows Update sagt,
lieber nicht.
Oh Gott, okay.
Und für die Leute gibt es dann halt
play.rustlang
und das
war super, weil da kannst du ihnen sagen,
okay, wir haben hier
einen Input als String,
versuch doch mal einen
Taschenrechner zu machen, der das einfach parst
in irgendwas oder vielleicht gleich
ausrechnet.
Je nach Level, die einen wollen dann AST bauen
und den dann komprimieren oder die anderen
wollen einfach sagen, wie ich informiere diese.
Je nach Level, die einen bauen erstmal
ein AST, sehr schön.
Merkst du, dass es wirklich unterschiedliche Level sind.
Was, du bist drittes Semester Informatik.
Du musstest gerade den AST in Haskell machen,
deswegen weißt du, dass du nicht jetzt...
Ich glaube, ein Taschenrechner war auch mein allererstes Programm
in BASIC damals, habe ich das gebastelt.
Und ich weiß noch, wie sehr ich daran verzweifelt bin,
weil ich es nicht hingekriegt habe,
das Programm so zu strukturieren,
dass du die erste Zahl, die Rechenart,
also dieses Symbol und dann die zweite Zahl eingibst.
Du musstest bei mir die Zahlen eingeben
und dann das Symbol.
Und ich konnte es einfach nicht, quasi
Suffix-Schreibweise, diese politische Notation.
Das ist doch auch nicht so.
Das ist aber andersrum.
Das ist vorne der Operand und dann
separiert die Teile.
Dann habe ich Reverse-Polish-Notation.
Reverse-Polish-Notation, ich glaube,
die ist doch die normale,
die heißt doch Reverse-Polish-Notation.
Ist die normale?
Ah, gut.
Wikipedia.
Du hattest aber gesagt, ihr habt irgendwie
drei unterschiedliche Sorten
Veranstaltungen gemacht. Das heißt, die eine ist so eine
Intro-Folge, wo ihr irgendwie eine Stunde
was erklärt und dann die Leute basteln lasst.
Und was sind die anderen?
Die zweite war
ein eher zugänglicheres
Thema, wenn es ging.
Also, wie
behandle ich Hashmaps
zum Beispiel? Oder wie
suche ich effizient? Wie benutze ich
zum Beispiel Iteratoren?
Und das dritte war...
Also wirklich fortgeschrittene Themen für Leute,
immer noch eine Introduction,
aber wie mache ich jetzt?
Genau, ein bisschen zugänglich.
Heute wird man wahrscheinlich versuchen,
WebAssembly dazunehmen,
sowas in die Richtung.
Und dann das dritte war dann
möglichst Hardcore-Technik,
keine Einführung.
Also die Einführung war dann so,
das sind Atomics, los geht's.
Achso, also du meinst,
dass diese drei Veranstaltungstypen
sind einfach drei Schwierigkeitsgrade,
aber es ist immer das Konzept,
wir machen jetzt einen Kurs quasi oder einen Rust-Kurs.
Ich dachte, du erzählst jetzt was wie,
wir haben immer eine Einführungsveranstaltung,
dann haben wir einen Vortrag und dann haben wir einen Hack-and-Learn,
wo einfach bloß so betreutes Coden ist oder sowas.
Aber du meinst wirklich, ihr habt da wirklich drei Kurse?
Habt ihr nicht auch Vorträge gehabt in eurem Meetup sogar?
Wir hatten eigentlich immer Vorträge, ja.
Also bis auf das Intro, was wirklich so Richtung Kurs angelegt war,
waren das immer Vorträge.
Wir haben uns auch sehr bemüht,
dass immer Leute von außen kommen und die halten.
und das ist eigentlich das Schwierigste
jetzt mit Corona, dass niemand von außen
Zeit und Muße hat
noch Vorträge
zu machen. Also ich habe, mein
Meetup ist ehrlich gesagt gestorben.
Das ist seitdem, mein letztes
war irgendwie den August vor Corona, dann habe ich
es eine Weile ruhen lassen, dann wollte ich es wieder anfangen
irgendwann und dann war plötzlich Pandemie
und seitdem habe ich keins mehr organisiert
bei mir.
Und
ich habe
mich dann auch ein bisschen darauf zurückgelehnt, naja,
jetzt sind ja die ganzen anderen Meetups,
die eigentlich auch
an sich viel besser organisiert sind
als meins, sind eh online, das heißt
jemand, der in Dresden wohnt, könnte sich ja jetzt
so online bei so einem Züricher oder
Berliner Rust-Meetup mit reinklinken,
was ich selber ja auch ein paar Mal gemacht habe.
Das habe ich auch in meiner Blase bemerkt.
Was in meiner Blase
ein bisschen mehr populärer ist als
ein Rust-Meetup, ist ein Coco-Heads-Meetup
für die Leute auf den Darwin-Plattformen.
Und
der Oliver Epper, ich glaube, der hört ja
zu, hi Oli, hat jetzt bei den Coco
Köln des öfteren
ein Meetup organisiert und da war ich jetzt auch mal mit
dabei. Das
ist echt schön, wenn man sich ein bisschen damit
geografisch breiter gefächert
jetzt einfach,
dass das normalisiert wird, dass man sich da breiter
gefächert
teilnehmen kann irgendwie oder
könnte man vorher potenziell ja auch, aber jetzt ist es
halt die Norm und es hat was, das ist
ein Feature. Was meint ihr,
wird das wieder weggehen?
Teilweise sicherlich, aber hoffentlich nicht komplett.
Ich denke, die Meetups, die wirklich gut ziehen, also so Berlin, Zürich weiß ich nicht, Linz sieht sehr gut aus,
Budapest könnte wieder gut kommen und vielleicht das in London wieder.
Die werden weiterhin aufnehmen und das raushauen und streamen, genau.
In Zürich hatten wir oft das Problem, dass
Aufnehmen gut ging und Streaming
eher so
ja.
Stabile WLAN-Verbindung
im Keller von einem Bürogebäude
ist halt doch Challenge.
Ja, das stimmt.
Dann an dem Veranstaltungsort das richtige
Netzwerk haben ist halt schwierig. Den musst du
dann quasi auch danach raussuchen. Deswegen ist es praktisch,
wenn du irgendwie die Uni hast
oder so. Obwohl an der Uni hat
dann eigentlich, nee, eigentlich war die Uni bei uns
verschriet, weil an der Uni niemand Internet
hatte, außer die Leute, die zufällig gerade studiert
haben.
Weil kein Mensch in das Eduroam
reinkam. Das war ein bisschen unpraktisch.
Man konnte ja Gastlogins
beantragen, aber die musst du so halt beantragen.
Ja,
aber ich denke schon, dass das
wieder mehr zu
dem persönlichen
Meetup wird in der Zukunft.
Also bald Treffen wieder
erlaubt werden, werden die Leute sagen,
Berufskollegen, mit denen ich nicht arbeite,
Check.
Dann gehe ich doch vorbei.
Auf jeden Fall.
Also jetzt, wo wir drüber reden, ich habe auch lange nicht mehr drüber nachgedacht,
aber ich bekomme irgendwie Bock, wieder mal so eins in Dresden
zu organisieren.
Bock mal eins zu besuchen.
Aber nicht, wenn ich von den Leuten vorher so einen
Test verlangen muss.
Wir sind ja bald bei den Impfungen.
Möchte ich mich auch sicher fühlen.
Das ist ja jetzt. In wenigen Wochen
alles abgehakt.
In wenigen Monaten sind wir alle durch.
Kostas Segway, wie ist denn bei euch die Impfsituation in der Schweiz?
Der deutsche Gesundheitsminister hat neulich gesagt, es ist schon jeder vierte geimpft und bald jeder fünfte.
War das die wirtschaftskompetente Spahn?
Genau, der gelernte Bankkaufmann.
Also Schweiz.
Das kann ja rauskriegen, das hatten wir glaube ich auch letzte Folge schon.
Ja. Ich schaue immer nach.
Doch, doch, ich muss,
weil das ist immer spannend.
Es heißt immer, wir sind so weit
und dann am Schluss
vom Tag, was schätzt
ihr? In der Schweiz?
Ich möchte behaupten, in der
Schweiz sind mehr Leute geimpft
als überall mehr Leute geimpft.
In Deutschland sind es jetzt
zur Zeit der Aufnahme gerade 33%.
In der Schweiz schätzt ich
sind es vielleicht 42%.
Kilian,
würdest du auch noch schätzen?
Ich hätte auch an die 40 jetzt geschätzt, grob.
25, Erstimpfung.
What?
Ja.
Okay, also wesentlich besser als in Deutschland,
weil...
Ach nee, warte, Erstimpfung?
Erstimpfung?
Wir haben 33% Erstimpfung.
Stimmt, wir haben 33% Erstimpfung,
wir haben irgendwie 8 oder 9% volle Impfung.
Okay, dann ist die Schweiz
und Deutschland ein Tick hinterher.
Ja, also
Zweitimpfungen sind es erst 12,5%.
Da seid ihr dann wiederum besser als
Deutschland, habe ich den Eindruck. Es gibt diesen schönen,
habt ihr das das letzte Mal schon erwähnt, ich folge dem auf Twitter,
dem Impfprogress.
Es gibt generell die wunderbare Seite
impfdashboard.de
wo das sehr sauber
und auch sehr hübsch aufbereitet ist.
Impfdashboard, packen wir mal
in die Shownotes.
Unbedingt.
Ja, und
um den Bogen mal wieder zurückzuspannen.
Also nicht das Sportgerät, das
Pfeile schießen kann, sondern
Kultur.
Ich habe vorhin Kieler noch einen Ohrwurm
besorgt.
Du solltest ihm auf keinen Fall
das Lied Brokkoli zeigen.
Okay, das kommt
auch in die Show Notes.
Verlinke ich euch, ja.
Um den Bogen nochmal
zurückzuspannen, also du hast gemeint,
zu Corona-Zeiten fällt der
dritte Typ bei euch aus, aber die anderen Sachen
Könnt ihr noch weitermachen bei
Meetup? Also der erste Typ fällt aus,
die Intros fallen aus.
Ja, weil das hilft
schon. Wir haben dann auch immer gesagt, dass wir zu
vier sind mindestens.
Und dann wirklich sagen, okay,
wir haben hier einen Tisch und
wir versuchen, dass möglichst
ein bis zwei Personen
pro bereits erfahrene
Rust-Entwicklerin
ist. Dass die Leute wirklich Fragen
stellen können. Und wir haben das auch so ausgeschrieben
und gesagt, hey, das ist wirklich für Anfänger,
es geht nur in die Grundlagen, hier sind die Slides,
hier ist das Demo-Projekt,
also eine Lösung für das
Beispielprojekt
und das war's. Und da sind auch
Leute gekommen, da waren wir auch schon bei
Hackerspaces zu Gast und das kam auch sehr gut
an.
Eine Zielgruppe, die ich nicht im Blick
hatte, ist
Ehefrauen von so
ultrakrassen Programmierern.
Die bringen da ihre
Frau mit und sagen,
Schau Schatz, die erklären dir jetzt, was ich bei der Arbeit mache.
Und da geht es nicht darum, dass sie programmieren lernen,
sondern einfach, dass sie ein bisschen versteht, was ihr Mann macht.
Das ist dann wahrscheinlich gut für die Beziehung.
Jetzt ist meine erste Frage, warum erklärt der Mann seiner Frau das dann nicht?
Oder andersrum, warum erklärt die Frau ihr Mann das dann nicht?
Aber ich habe auch schon mitbekommen, dass manchmal Leute, die Partner von Entwicklern sind,
die Interesse daran haben, ein Einstieg zu finden, teilweise es schwieriger haben.
weil du irgendwie den
Druck hast, dass du ja bereits jemanden hast,
der das kann, den du fragen könntest, aber du willst auch nicht
die ganze Zeit darüber reden oder
du machst es dann einfach irgendwie nicht.
Irgendwie hatte ich das schon ein paar Mal
gesehen, dass
aber egal, das ist jetzt ein bisschen
daneben.
Es kann auch
sein, dass du dann zu steil
einsteigst.
Weil du
Du willst dann gleich dieses so perfekt abstrahierte Teil haben.
Ich bring dir das einfach alles bei und dann ist es so eine Überfrachtung.
Das kann gut sein.
Die sind dann voll dahinter und dann wird quasi mit Kanonen auf Spatzen geschossen,
anstatt dass das so ein softer Einstieg ist, wo du sagst, hier mal so ein bisschen.
Oder vielleicht lässt man sich sowas auch von einem Fremden lieber erklären.
Das auch, ja.
Aber das ist jetzt ein sehr spekulatives Feld.
Sehr spekulativ.
sehr ungern Nachhilfe von meinem Dad bekommt.
Es hat immer in Tränen geendet.
Von anderen Leuten war es gar kein Problem,
aber wenn mein Dad mir Mathe-Nachhilfe gegeben hat,
nee, das ging nicht.
Das war schlimm.
Es gibt wahrscheinlich so Sachen,
das ist wie über Arbeit reden mit dem Partner oder sowas.
Das ist vielleicht nicht...
Ja, es gibt gewisse Themen, die gehen einfach nicht, das stimmt.
Ja.
Ja, der Freund von einer guten Freundin hatte das auch.
Der hatte sehr frustrierende Kunden,
die sie im Geschäft bedienen mussten.
Und dann Informatik hat bei ihm dann so
halt so dieses Laden runter abschalten ausgelöst.
Und dann kann ich schon verstehen,
dass dann du sagst,
ja, ich will es trotzdem wissen,
ich frage jetzt halt andere Leute.
Also Frauen allgemein können ja eigentlich alles.
Was man fürs Programmieren braucht,
es fehlt nichts.
Du musst lesen und schreiben können.
interessante Thematiken, die wir gerade
haben, steigen hier.
Es wird zu oft
einfach ignoriert. Man sagt sich so,
ja, die Leute, die es interessiert, die kommen dann schon.
Ja,
die Leute kommen, aber es gibt auch viele Leute,
die haben
ein bisschen viel Freizeit und die kann man abholen
und dann kann man sich auch aussuchen,
in welche Richtung man die Community
entwickeln möchte.
Die Leute wissen auch manchmal gar nicht, was sie interessiert.
Manchmal
kriegt man ja irgendwie so einen
Intro zu irgendwas, wo du dir denkst,
das ist ja krass, da habe ich ja noch nie
von gehört, das mache ich jetzt. Das finde ich
total spannend, wusste ich gar nicht, dass es das gibt.
Es gibt ja viele Leute, die
programmieren für furchtbar langweilig,
bis sie das das erste Mal gemacht haben.
Und dann stellen sie fest,
das ist furchtbar langweilig.
Ja, und dann sagen sie, wenn ich ein Problem
habe, dann löse ich das.
Wenn ich einmal angefixt bin, dann möchte ich dieses Problem
lösen. Wir haben zu vielen Sachen.
Man kann halt Spaß von haben. Also ich weiß nicht,
Steuerberater auch in der Freizeit
sich sowas anschauen. Also wenn du da einen
kennst, den kannst du mir gerne mal vorbeischicken.
Man kann damit
viel im Spaß haben.
Ich will die ganze Zeit den Bogen spannen zu, wie gut funktioniert
das jetzt in
der Pandemie?
Intros?
Allgemein so das Mieter für dich.
Ich habe bloß diesen Vergleich. Ich habe meins komplett
abgebrochen. Meins findet quasi
nicht mehr statt.
Wie ist das bei euch? Aber ihr wart ja schon immer
Team von vier, fünf Leute?
Wir waren mal fünf Leute,
ja. Genau.
Und dann hat
die
Wasia hat dann eine Professorenstelle
bekommen in den USA.
Zeitzonen
sind wirklich schwer zum Überbrücken.
Also da muss sehr viel
persönliche Verbindung da sein,
dass du über
mehr als eine Zeitstunde weg etwas
organisierst. Es ist dann immer
in deiner Nacht oder
in komischen Zeiten.
Das ist ein bisschen tricky, das stimmt.
Genau.
Das flasht mich immer, wenn mich Jupp anschreibt,
weil ich dann überlege, wie spät ist es bei dem gerade.
Heute früh schreibt er mir...
Warte, was hat er geschrieben?
Achso, heute früh hat er mir geschrieben
Haha, keine Hose.
Wann hat er mir das geschrieben?
Heute um 10. Das war wirklich eine Uhrzeit,
wo bei ihm irgendwie nachts um 2 ist.
Da hat er schon einen Unterschied um 1 Uhr.
Krass, ne? Krass.
schön, dass er um 1 Uhr nachts
uns hört und darüber
erheitert wird. Er hat ja mal gesagt, dass er uns zum
Einschlafen hört.
Ja, also Meetups funktionieren in der Pandemie
also schlechter und wenn du mehr Zeit zu hohen hast, dann
noch schlechter.
Oder besser,
das ist auch lustig, für die,
die Vorträge geben, kann das
zum Teil super passen,
wenn die über ihren Mittag
deinen Vortrag füllen.
Und die Leute hören das am Abend.
Ich spreche mal eben in der Mittagspause
auf einem Meetup oder sowas.
Das ist ja auch kanzig.
Dann machst du eine Stunde
und etwas Mittag
und gibst in Europa den Vortrag
und in Japan
ist das Abend zu der Zeit.
Die hören das dann auf dem Heimweg.
Finde ich neue Möglichkeiten.
Und für uns sind dann USA.
Das muss dann
wirklich zufällig dieser 9 Stunden
oder 8 Stunden Unterschied sein.
Der nächste Schritt ist aus dem ÖPNV heraus ein Meetup halten.
Warte mal, Entschuldigung.
Nee, ich kann nicht ausdenken.
Entschuldigung, einen kleinen Moment,
ich muss hier mal kurz aussteigen.
Ich halte gerade eine Prästation
für 100 Leuten.
Meine Fahrkarte,
nee, meine Fahrkarte,
wartet mal kurz,
dann ist er weg, weil er das WLAN aus dem Zug benutzt hat
Ja, okay, also
die zwei Parten Meetups, die wir noch hatten
die allgemein zugänglicheren
und die
sehr technischen, die haben wir
immer noch gemacht
und das gab
wieder mal Rustfest gab es
diesen Impuls weiterzubachen
weil es wurde irgendwann
klar, dass wir nicht in die Niederlande
können, leider
sehr traurig
und dann haben wir gesagt
okay, wir müssen uns
die ganzen Technologie-Stacks
anschauen, die es so gibt
wie kann man präsentieren
wir haben ein Meetup gemacht
mit Jitsi
damals, als Jitsi
noch relativ instabil war, haben wir
versucht ein Meetup zu machen mit Jitsi
und dann gesagt, ah
lieber nicht
dann haben wir mit
OBS
rumgespielt. Wir haben drei
Metaps mit OBS und
UDP gemacht.
Also das ging dann...
Hat OBS auch irgendwie ein Streaming
Backend oder ist das wirklich
krass?
OBS heißt ja Open
Broadcasting Studio.
Ich kenne aber bloß den
Teil, der dann meinen Webcam-Feed
verwurstet und irgendwie den Hintergrund austauscht.
Den Rest habe ich noch nicht mehr. OBS ist so das
Tool für die ganzen Twitch-Streamer.
Ja klar, aber die schicken es bloß bis zu Twitch.
Achso, du meinst, es gibt kein Receiving.
Nein, die Twitch-Streamer, die machen alles lokal mit OBS und Plugins und so.
Also wenn du dann siehst, wie dir da so Herzchen und Namen und irgendwas alles einblendet,
das machen die lokal und was die zu Twitch schicken, ist RTMP.
Ja, aber die Leute, die diesen Twitch angucken, gucken den über Twitch
und die Leute, die sich dein Meetup angucken, gucken, es sieht jetzt nicht über Twitch an,
sondern was ist denn da die zentrale Verteilerstelle.
auch ein OBS, oder was habt ihr da genommen?
Wir haben es tatsächlich
über Twitch gemacht am Anfang.
Achso, also doch, okay.
Also wir hatten bei
wir hatten
Danilo in Rapperswil,
der hat
genug Kontrolle gehabt über
seine NAT-Firewall, dass wir da mit
IPv4 und 6 einfach reinkommen.
Dann hat er einfach
UDP-Ports auf der Firewall aufgemacht
und reingemackt in sein lokales Netzwerk.
Und dann hatten wir von außen, ich hatte zwei OBS-Instanzen am Anfang.
Und nach viel Programmieren haben wir es dann herausgefunden,
das Beste, was du machen kannst, ist, du hast einmal VLC, der deine Webcam abgreift
und einfach auf ein UDP-Socket draufspickt.
Und dann ein zweites Mal VLC, das deinen Bildschirm abgreift und auf einen anderen Port schickt.
Und das machen dann alle, die einen Vortrag
halten. Dann haben wir jetzt die
Command Line, das ist so ein Dreizeiler.
Und dann
hat Daniel
das bei sich gemixt und war
dann sozusagen
das Studio. Ich habe dann
oft MC gemacht
und andere Leute haben präsentiert.
Abgefahren. Das heißt,
du redest das
vom Meetup oder vom Rustfest?
Vom Meetup. Also wir haben das
ausprobiert und haben gemerkt, das ist die
beste Art, wie du Meetup machen kannst.
Wenn alle
VLC installieren können und Commandline bedienen
können, dann schickst du ihnen per E-Mail einen Link.
Da ist alles hart drin,
also Portnummern, IP-Adressen,
alles. Und die
kopieren das einfach in ihre Shell rein
und das geht durchs Internet durch.
Unverschlüsselt,
aber es geht.
So macht man das.
Schaut ihr euch die
SN,
Starship-Starts an?
Die SpaceX-Starship-Starts?
Ja, manchmal.
Also, sie explodieren in der Zwischenzeit
ein bisschen oft.
Sie explodieren in letzter Zeit weniger.
Sie kippen einfach schon vorher um.
Die 15 ist tatsächlich sauber gelandet
und nicht explodiert hinterher.
Und da war,
ich gucke das immer mal,
ich habe damit auch meinen Vater so ein bisschen
angefixt und der schickt mir jetzt bei jedem
läpperten anderen
SpaceX-Start auch noch,
Ja, guck mal, ist gerade ein Video.
Aber zumindest
auf dem Feed hat man neulich erkannt,
dass der Feed von der Rakete,
den man da in dem YouTube-Stream
gesehen hat, auch via VLC
kam. Da wurde nämlich genau dieser
VLC, dann stand da UDP
und eine IP-Adresse, die
wahrscheinlich über Starlink
geteilt wurde,
in dem Feed drin.
Sehr cool.
Wir hätten fast VPN
aufgesetzt, aber dann haben wir gemerkt,
Port-Forwarding reicht, eigentlich.
Und was wir dann aber
auch feststellen mussten, für
eine Konferenz, wo du
einen Redner nach der nächsten
Rednerin hast, geht das nicht.
Also,
du brauchst dann halt immer
10-15 Minuten.
Diese Lobby, wo du irgendwie mal
kurz den Moderator wieder reinschaltest,
dann brauchst du irgendwie so ein Backstage,
wo du die Leute schon mal antesten kannst, bevor du es
auf den Livestream stellst.
Ja, du hast gerade die Wunschliste
für das nächste Rustfest erraten
weil das hatten wir nicht
bei
Habt ihr euch mal mit den Leuten
unterhalten, die
den Kongress machen?
Die haben doch auch eine total abgefahrene, mittlerweile komplett
Open Source Video Infrastruktur
Das WOC damit reinziehen klingt eigentlich
Das WOC, genau
Ja
Das ist genau das Ding, du brauchst dann das WOC
weil die Infrastruktur kann alles
aber sie ist halt super komplex
Achso, du brauchst natürlich auch Leute
die die Skills drauf haben, diese Infrastruktur zu bedienen
Und die Hardware, ja
Machen die das nicht mit? Da habe ich ja nicht mal irgendwo eine Webseite
gesehen, dass du das Wok quasi
mieten kannst
Die sind nicht nur quasi in der Auskruppung gemacht
Die haben auch andere Veranstaltungen, die haben auch schon
andere
Konferenzen oder Meetups
Also Rustfest Rome wurde zum Beispiel
vom Wok gemacht
Ich habe ja eine relativ kleine Filterblase
Deswegen muss es ein Rastfest gewesen sein.
Ja, es gibt auch andere.
Also die CCC-nahen
Dinge werden oft,
also die Konferenzen Gulaschprogrammiernacht
und
Cosin aus der Schweiz
werden alle vom WOG gemacht.
Es gibt inzwischen auch ein CH-WOG
und
wenn ich die Hardware
richtig verstanden habe, braucht es einen Tower
und dann
irgendeine starke
die halt in Hardware H.265
codieren können. Achso.
Da musst du natürlich encoden können in Hardware.
Genau.
Und da brauchst du noch Kameras, Stative
und Leute, die das bedienen
und den ganzen Rest kannst du
mit XML steuern.
Genau, von der ganzen
Hardware mal abgesehen, die hast du ja
bei so einem verteilten Remote-Meetup
oder einer Konferenz nicht.
Oder brauchst du nicht, weil jeder immer bloß seine Webcam
und seinen Bildschirm dateilt.
Ja,
es wird besser, aber du bist dann halt sehr schnell,
ja, dann musst du Software installieren
und dann brauchst du das noch und dann vielleicht noch das.
Und es sind dann halt einfach mehrere Schritte.
Und ich habe so das Gefühl,
so nach drei, vier Schritten sagen die Leute,
ah, doch nicht.
Und darum, diese drei Schritte solltest du aufsparen
für irgendwie vernünftigen Ton.
Wenn es geht, ein bisschen Licht und den Vortrag.
Und das Übertragen sollte eigentlich browserbasiert sein.
Also so, klick diesen Link an, wir machen den Rest.
Gib uns vielleicht noch Zugriff auf deinen Bildschirm.
Und das funktioniert sehr gut mit Jitsi.
Das Meetup von Linz macht es mit Zoom.
Und da gibt es noch eins.
Das, was wir für Rustfest hatten, StreamYard,
ist eine abgespeckte OBS-Version im Browser.
Kannst du Einladungslinks schicken und die Leute machen das
und dann können die Veranstalterinnen alles machen.
Also so Panels rumschieben, Folien links, Schicker rechts
oder nur die Leute, die reden, nur die Folien.
Das geht alles.
Das Einzige, was du den Leuten dann sagen musst mit StreamYard,
vielleicht nicht mit zwei Bildschirmen präsentieren,
weil das dann manchmal den Browser verwirbt.
Aber sonst ist das die einfachste Lösung,
wenn das etwas browserbasiert ist.
Installieren, wenn die Leute das nicht schon haben.
Ja, Web for the win.
Ja.
Definitiv.
Das ist echt wahr.
Das macht es easier.
Sorry.
Sag.
Nee, ich meine, du machst es gerade für sowas halt easier,
für Sachen, die du nicht regelmäßig brauchst,
das Onboarding möglichst easy ist,
wenn du Leuten sagst, hier Link fertig läuft,
wunderbar.
Onboarding.
Und dann,
was ich gemerkt habe, ist, dass es
manchmal hilft,
einfach doch selber einen Vortrag zu machen.
Also,
ich versuche, ein bis zwei
Vorträge zu geben pro Jahr.
Ah, krass.
Ja.
Aber da ist schon eine ganze Menge Arbeit drin, oder?
Mhm.
Ja.
Du musst ein bisschen Glück haben mit den Themen,
weil wenn du dich hinsetzt und sagst,
ich mache jetzt einen coolen Vortrag,
dann kommt nichts in der Regel.
Wird nichts, auf jeden Fall.
So geht es mir.
Genau, aber vielleicht hast du ja irgendwie
irgendeinen Mitarbeiter, Kunden oder einen Chef,
der dir sagt,
das Thema, das müsste man sich mal anschauen.
Und dann denkst du dir vielleicht,
okay, darüber mache ich jetzt einen Vortrag.
Dann schaue ich mir das mit dem Vortrag an.
Oder du machst sowieso irgendeine Analyse von einer Technologie.
Das habe ich mir so als Vorwand genommen,
zu sagen, irgendwann halte ich mal bei uns auf einem Webmeetup in Dresden oder sowas,
am Webmontag halte ich mal einen Vortrag über Web-Audio,
wollte ich mich schon immer mal reinarbeiten.
Vortrag habe ich, glaube ich, auch nie gehalten.
Hast du nicht?
Was hast du da gesprochen? WebAssembly.
Irgendwas mit Web.
Wie sich bei dem Meetup ja gar nicht
ermietet.
Hast du dich dann beim Einarbeiten
im WebAudio irgendwie
mit WebAssembly beschäftigen müssen?
Und dann hast du gedacht, das ist schon
groß genug? Nee, WebAssembly war einfach so geil und ich hatte
mal Bock, einen Vortrag über WebAssembly zu halten.
Und das hatte nichts mit WebAudio an der Stelle
zu tun. Man kann die beiden auch ganz gut mischen,
auf jeden Fall. Aber
Das Problem, was ich dann hatte, war, der Vortrag ist zu einem
übelsten Brett geworden. Also der hatte irgendwie
60 Folien und war,
da waren die Leute tatsächlich
vollends informiert, als der vorbei war
bei dem WebAssembly-Vortrag. Du hattest vorher noch
nie was davon gehört und nicht da wusstest du,
wie man Rust nach WebAssembly kombiniert.
Das war, glaube ich, ein bisschen viel.
Aber war alles drin, inklusive Demo. Das war cool.
Aber wir hatten Streaming-Technologie.
Ja, Streaming-Technologie. So, jetzt hast du also
dein Meetup komplett in die Cloud
verschoben und machst das alles online.
Und du könntest dir vorstellen,
dass du es so weiterlaufen lässt oder
du machst es ja jetzt schon ein Weilchen,
oder?
Ja, sind es dann vier Jahre.
Vier Jahre, wir machen das hier seit vier Jahren.
So ist es.
Und was auch
ein Problem ist, was mir aufgefallen ist bei meinem,
ist zwar, manchmal kriegt man es hin,
dass Leute kommen, sich das angucken, man kriegt es auch
vielleicht manchmal hin, dass jemand einen Vortrag hält,
was richtig schwierig ist, sich jemanden zu motivieren,
zu sagen, du, ich nehme dir mal
von diesem Dings.
Da hat mir
in Dresden der
Henrik, keinerlei
Verwechslungsgefahr,
von Henrik Skopin
auch sehr viel Arbeit abgenommen.
Wir haben abwechselnd einen Mozilla und einen Rust-Meetup gemacht.
Aber allgemein
so bei Organisationen,
nicht nur bei Meetups, aber auch bei anderen
Organisationen, wo du was mit Herzblut machst,
ist manchmal schwierig, Leute zu finden,
die dann sagen, pass auf, ich nehme dir das mal ein bisschen
aus der Hand. Weil so ein Meetup möchtest du ja vielleicht
auch nicht ewig alleine weitermachen.
Vielleicht möchtest du, dass ich da mal eine Runde ausklinge
und mal was anderes machen und schauen, dass es nicht sofort
stirbt, wenn du irgendwie das Ruder
aus der Hand gibst.
Keon und ich waren in einem Studentenverein
und da haben wir auch immer geschaut,
dass wir jemanden finden, an dem wir das
dem wir als nächstes
die Verantwortung in die Hand drücken können. Wie ist denn da deine
Erfahrung?
Zum einen habe ich jetzt
gerade vergessen
zu erwähnen, dass wir ja noch ein anderes
großes Meetup in Zürich hatten, zwar das
Meetup.
Ja, die habe ich leider
vergessen.
Und zwar hatten die
ein Dual Meetup
zwischen Bern und Zürich. Also der
Hauptstadt und der größten Stadt der Schweiz.
Und die haben
uns dann...
Zürich ist die große.
Ah ja.
Ich habe nicht Spaß gemacht.
Genau.
Und sie hatten
uns halt unterstützt am Anfang.
gesagt, hey, kommt auf unsere
Meetup-Plattform.
Dann haben wir die eigene Gruppe gemacht.
Beziehungsweise wir haben die Gruppe von jemand
übernommen, der hat das Meetup gemacht
zum 1.0 Release
und dann
nie wieder, es schlief total ein.
Wir haben dann Kontakt
herstellen können zum Glück.
Und der hat gesagt, hey, ich sponsere euch
die 50 US-Dollar
pro Jahr,
damit ihr weiter
Meetups organisieren könnt.
Und die Leute hatten in diesem Sinne einfach Glück, dass neue Leute gekommen sind, die gesagt haben, das ist etwas, was uns interessiert.
Wir haben das Bedürfnis, vielleicht weil wir ein Problem lösen wollen oder weil wir uns besser in die Materie einarbeiten wollten oder weil wir uns in der Richtung selbstständig machen wollten.
Also das Thema kam relativ früh auf.
Wir haben gesagt, ja, wir brauchen halt die Kontakte.
Das ist auch eine Motivation.
Also wenn du sagst, du willst mit dieser Technologie in dieser Stadt arbeiten, ist das eine gute Idee, ein Meetup durchzuführen, ein paar Vorträge zu geben, allen Leuten zu sagen, hey, ich kann das, es hat noch mehr Leute in der Gegend.
Also die Motivation ist da, wenn du jemand bist, der Arbeitgeber ist zum Beispiel, meinst du, der Leute sucht, die das irgendwann können und dann für dich arbeiten.
Genau, nur sind Arbeitgeber oft nicht in dieser Schiene drin,
dass sie sagen, ich organisiere jetzt etwas.
Die machen eher so Werbeevents und dann kommt jemand.
Oder sie gehen zur Berufsmessie und dann kommen nur Leute,
die so, ja, ich kann alles, ich kann alles programmieren.
Und Kalman, dynamisch und so, piu piu.
Wir haben es mehr aus der Sicht rausgemacht.
wir möchten nach dem Studium
irgendwo arbeiten können, wo sie
Rast brauchen.
Das ist gut, das ist gut.
Also
Stellensuchende. Aber habt ihr
Leute gefunden, die
seitdem nach euch
in der Organisation von dem Meetup
eingestiegen sind und selber
mit Veranstaltungen organisieren und das mitmanagen?
Oder ist das noch der harte Kern,
die das
von Anfang an gemacht haben?
Es ist noch ein Teil vom harten Kern übrig.
Und Gary, falls du das hörst,
vielleicht übernimmst du dann irgendwann das Meetup in Zürich.
Wir haben jetzt ein-, zweimal Leute gefunden.
Kein Druck.
Die sagen, hey, ich organisiere mal einen Vortrag.
Und dann sagen wir, super, unterstützen wir.
Also unterstütze ich die Leute dabei,
hey, finde Leute, die du sehr toll findest,
wenn du sie anschreibst und ihnen sagst,
hey, in Zürich hast du Leute, die haben Erfahrung mit dem ganzen Streaming-Zeug,
du machst einfach deine Folien oder deine Demo
und die erklärt dir dann in fünf Minuten den Rest,
dann ist das ein Einstieg in die Organisation,
wie man ein Ding organisiert.
Es kann natürlich sein, dass die Leute dann sagen,
aha, ich habe jetzt diese Fähigkeit erlernen,
ich mache jetzt mein anderes Ding.
Kann sein, oder sie das Interesse verlieren.
Ja, genau.
Hallo Bender.
Das kann sein.
Aber was hat die,
sagt man?
Es ist ein ungelöstes Problem,
eigentlich so ein bisschen Nachwuchs zu finden.
Manchmal klappt es, manchmal nicht.
Irgendwie muss man wahrscheinlich den Leuten
noch so das Gefühl geben,
das ist jetzt hier dein eigenes Ding.
Du musst nicht einfach bloß meine Arbeit weitermachen.
Hauptsache, es macht jemand,
sondern ihr habt euch ja mit eurem Meetup
und mit eurer Organisation,
ich denke jetzt an jedwede Organisation,
jemand aufbaut und dann vielleicht Nachwuchs
sucht. Ich denke jetzt auch an unser Studentencafé.
Man muss irgendwie demjenigen, der
in deiner Fußstapfen tritt, das Gefühl
geben können, du kannst dich ja selbst verwirklichen
und musst nicht einfach bloß irgendwie dasselbe
weitermachen, was andere Leute aufgebaut haben.
Und gleichzeitig darfst du nicht das Gefühl
vermitteln, es ist alles egal, habt ihr, es macht
jemand. Also diese
Balance zwischen, wir hätten gerne
so ein bisschen in die Richtung,
also jetzt bei dem Thema Rust zum Beispiel
und wir hätten gerne
Qualität, wir hatten gerne mehrere
Vorträge, es ist okay, wenn es Pausen
gibt und du darfst auch gerne selber
vortragen oder eigene Themen und
eigene Leute bringen und dann
kommt das, was man
halt selber
akzeptieren muss, dass
Leute es anders machen,
zum einen, oder
dass, wenn man es dann übergeben hat, dass
es stirbt. Das kann
trotzdem passieren.
Man darf dann nicht böse sein, wenn die
Leute dann das Interesse verlieren, dann kann man
okay, vielleicht kommt es doch, vielleicht bist du zu ungeduldig und hast einen Tränen,
ja, wir haben jeden Monat und jetzt gibt es zwei Monate, eine Pause, was ist denn da los?
Vielleicht kommt es dann im vierten Monat und wenn du es dann wieder selber machen willst,
dann kannst du es ja wieder selber machen.
Was einfach schlecht wäre,
wenn du
übergibst und dann
immer so von hinten noch dazu
Der alte Mann,
der den Neuen über die Schulter schaut.
Naja,
das ist eine Gefahr.
Oder die Mama, die beim Fahren dann
immer sagt, so, jetzt schau nach rechts
und nach links.
Vom Rücksitzhaus.
Das ist sicherlich auch ein Problem, was viele
Open-Source-Projekte haben.
dass du irgendwie, dass du was abgibst,
was du irgendwie zehn Jahre entwickelt hast und dann
gibst du es weiter
jemand anders und der schreibt das dann irgendwie
oben auf eine Art und Weise, die du nicht magst.
Manchmal bist du das aber auch einfach selber.
Manchmal nimmst du irgendwie...
Warum ist es eigentlich so, dass wenn ich so ein Softwareprojekt
wieder in der Hand nehme,
was ich selber...
Was ich selber
drei Jahre entwickelt habe und mir dann
mit ein, zwei Jahren Abstand nochmal
angucke, dass ich das immer scheiße finde,
was ich damals gemacht habe.
Zukunfts-Ich
und Vergangenheits-Ich sind da
komplett unterschiedlicher Auffassung.
Woher kommt das?
Du hast ja auch viel gelernt in der Zwischenzeit.
Vielleicht irgendwelche Best Practices, vielleicht sogar
eine ganz andere Sprache oder nur andere
Frameworks und willst natürlich auch
das benutzen, was du in der Zwischenzeit gelernt hast
und schaust halt auf
vor allem die Sachen, die du früher gemacht hast
mit den Augen, von wegen, das hat
dein ungebildetes Ich gebaut
und entwickelt und sich drüber
Gedanken gemacht. Und ich glaube, man ist ein bisschen kritischer mit sich
selbst als noch mit anderen Leuten,
die ja potenziell
sowieso klüger sind als ich.
Meinst du, wenn du deinem vergangenen Ich begegnen
würdest, so fünf Jahre, zehn Jahre her,
wärst du total so herablassend
und vatermäßig?
Ich habe schon häufig darüber nachgedacht in der Situation,
was ich in meinem Vergangenheit für Tipps geben würde
und
was ich so ändern würde.
Aber gleichzeitig würde das natürlich natürlich,
je nachdem, welcher Zeitreisetheorie
man subscribt hat, ganz witzige
Konsequenzen mit sich ziehen. Nehmen wir mal
das Alternative Universe. Du kannst
in der Vergangenheit zurücktreiben.
Dann ist es eh irrelevant, dann bringt es mir ja nichts.
Also du würdest es nur aufgrund des eigenen Vorteils machen?
Wenn ich schon mit mir selber rede, natürlich geht es um
den eigenen Vorteil.
Aber gleichzeitig wäre es natürlich auch
interessant, meine
vergangene Perspektive von mir selbst
erläutert zu bekommen, weil ich meine, ich habe ja eh die Hälfte
vergessen. Die Hälfte ist gut unterschätzt.
Wahrscheinlich so 80% vergessen
von dem, was ich früher gedacht habe, zu Dingen.
Aber gleichzeitig war ich ja auch
ein, also ich meine, gut, ich habe einfach dieses Bild von mir,
dass ich ein naiver Vollidiot war, aber ich habe
halt, wie ich schon mal meinte,
auch dieses Bild von mir in der Zukunft,
dass ich wahrscheinlich ein naiver Vollidiot sein werde.
Also Präsenz-Kirjan ist immer der
Beste.
Du bist jetzt noch kein naiver
Vollidiot, aber du wirst es mal sein.
Ich habe Angst, dass ich so ein konservativer alter Spack werde.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich habe nur die Angst,
es ist völlig irrational, aber das Problem ist,
wenn es so wäre, ich kann nichts daran ändern,
weil der Zukunftskirchen ist ja derjenige, der dann im Präsens sitzt und über Vergangenheitskirchen, aka mich, lacht.
Und ich habe ja nichts mehr zu sagen, mich gibt es ja nicht mehr.
Zukunftskirchen hat die Deutungshoheit.
Ja eben, das ist das Problem an der Sache.
Ich bin ein bisschen abgetreffelt, tut mir leid.
Da fällt mir ein Schröder-Zitat ein.
Oh Gott, welcher Schröder?
Der Gerald, der Altkanzler da von Deutschland, der hat in einem Interview Jungs gesagt,
Ich habe als Bundeskanzler die Revolution verhindert, die ich als junger Mann selbst organisiert hatte.
Schön.
Scheiße.
Ja.
Blöd liefst.
Deswegen darf man Leute ab einem gewissen Alter nicht mehr regieren lassen.
Die Baerbocker sind fast zu alt, ehrlich gesagt, um Bundeskanzlerin zu werden.
Aber ihre Initialien passen so schön.
Ich würde gerne zumindest eine Amtsperiode eine Kanzlerin haben, deren Initialien ACAB sind.
Das kann man so richtig schön in die Welt tragen.
Ich glaube, damit wird sie auch in der Geschichte bleiben.
Du meinst, dass die schon seit Jahrzehnten Leute Wahlwerbung für sie auf den Straßen machen mit Graffiti?
Das ist auf jeden Fall die akronomisierbarste Kanzlerin, die wir je hatten.
Das ist auf jeden Fall.
Sehr schön.
Haben wir noch was? Mal schauen.
Ja, zum Leute finden.
Also, ich würde sagen,
das Einfachste ist, man muss
einen guten Nährboden schaffen.
Sagen, schaut,
das ist ein Umfeld
und es ist nicht nur der Vortrag,
sondern es ist auch das Umfeld.
Gewisse
Meetups gibt es immer Pizza,
bei anderen gibt es nichts.
Das habe ich falsch gemacht.
Pizza?
Ich habe nie Pizza bestellt.
Ich habe einfach bloß...
Das war es. Sorry.
Warum kommen die Leute dann?
Ist das wegen der Pizza oder ist das wegen dem Thema?
Das ist wahrscheinlich die Pizza.
Das ist die Frage.
Wir haben gemerkt, wir hatten
bei vielen Meetups Pizza.
Die Pizza war nicht das ausschlaggebende.
Das war das Thema.
Die Pizza ist so ein
nice to have, das gibt dir so einen kleinen Boost.
Dann habt ihr es doch richtig gemacht.
Erinnert ihr euch noch an die Zeit
BC, also bevor Corona, wo man
gemeinsam aus demselben
Pizzakarton gegessen hat.
Oh ja, wo du so
sechs Pizzakartons hattest und du konntest
von jedem ein Stück nehmen.
Das ist sowas von unhygienisch, aber
ob wir irgendwann wieder an den Punkt kommen, wo man
mehrere fremde Hände in dieselbe
Kiste greifen.
Pizza.
Kleiner Spoiler.
Zukünftiges Ich wird sich wahrscheinlich
heute eine Pizza holen.
Das ist eine sehr gute Idee.
Du meinst ein sehr naher Zukunfts-Doo.
Ich glaube, das machen wir auch, oder?
Holen wir uns jetzt noch eine Pizza?
Klingt gut.
Pizza ist immer gut.
Kann man nie was falsch machen eigentlich.
Doch, ich habe einmal eine ekelhafte Pizza gegessen.
Sei mal enthusiastisch, sag mal Ja.
Ja, ja, total.
Ich habe mal eine Pizza mit Nutella gegessen,
wollte ich sogar sagen, die war richtig widerlich.
Das war sogar in einer echten Pizzeria.
Ich weiß nicht, wie die das verbrechen konnten.
Ich glaube, jeder probiert mal aus, irgendwo Nutella drauf zu machen,
wo es nicht hin gehört.
Ja, das gehört wirklich nicht hin.
Ich wollte nur warnen vor Gummibären auf Pizza.
Das ist noch schlimmer.
Aber ja, das andere, was halt ist,
wenn du dann die Leute hast, mit oder ohne Pizza,
was ich nicht empfehlen kann, sind Süßigkeiten.
Nicht? Was kann denn da schief gehen?
Meinst du Zucker bringt die Leute weg oder was?
Zucker macht die Leute nervös und so schnellschüssig.
bist du ja an dem Meetup und du lernst
Leute erst ein bisschen kennen, du kennst ja die
meisten Leute nicht, du hast ja bei einem
In-Person-Meetup
vielleicht ein Drittel der Leute,
die regelmäßig kommen
und zwei Drittel sind jedes Mal neu.
Das heißt, du musst eher
entschleunigen, also
vielleicht
Kaffee, wenn es in irgendeinem Büro
ist, oder vielleicht wenig
Bier, aber es soll kein Gelage
werden, oder man kann auch sagen, wir machen
überhaupt kein Bier, also
von Rust haben wir uns
geeinigt darauf, dass wir keine
Volksdrogen
verteilen. Also es gibt
Brot oder Nüsschen
oder Salzstangen,
Wasser oder Saft
und dann, wenn
die...
Ja, man kann auch selber zum
x-beliebten Markt gehen
und dann holt man sich so ein Sixpack.
Oder manchmal wird es halt gesponsert.
Wir hatten auch schon die Diskussion
mit einer Firma, der hat gesagt, ja, wir machen
euch den Kühlschrank auf und der so, ja,
ist super lieb, aber wir hätten
lieber den Kühlschrank ohne das Bier.
Ja, das ist halt im gleichen
Kühlschrank, das ist ein Problem. Nein, natürlich nicht.
Und dann stellst
du halt das Bier nicht auf den Tresen und wenn
jemand dann weiß, dass es in dem
Kühlschrank Bier hat, dann nehmen sie sich halt Bier.
Das ist dann,
also es ist so das
Grundding,
du musst halt das definieren, wie du das haben
möchtest in deiner Community und
dann kann die Leute das gut finden oder schlecht.
Und wenn das dann mit guten Vorträgen zusammenfällt,
dann kommen dann Leute und dann kommen auch Anfragen.
Und da ist das Kritische, man muss sehr schnell auf die Leute antworten.
Wenn sie was machen wollen, dass sie nicht zu lange hingehalten werden.
Genau. Maximal 24 Stunden oder Wochenende bloß 24 Stunden.
Und dann antworten.
Weil wenn man langsamer ist, dann haben die Leute so ein Gefühl,
die sind ein bisschen langsam
und dann ist das Interesse weg.
Wir hatten immer mal
Meetups, auch
andere Meetups bei uns im Büro
in der Firma organisiert, da war dann meine Firma
Sponsor und die haben sich dann
natürlich, da wurde dann Bier hingestellt
und dann hat man manchmal am nächsten Tag noch Bier
im Büro.
Das ist ein bisschen gefährlich.
Er hat mich ja meinen.
Versagt man dann nach dem Feierabend auf ein Bier
im Büro mit einem Kollegen.
Ich habe mein Praktikum bei Audi damals, mein Schulzeitpraktikum, wo ich ein bisschen geflasht davon war,
dass du natürlich jederzeit, immer zu jeder Tageszeit dort Bier bekommst, weil das gehört halt einfach dazu, zum Arbeitsumfeld.
Das könnte die Verarbeitungsqualität von diesen Autos erklären.
Wäre nur schlechter ohne, glaube ich.
Nee, Audi sind ja ganz gute Autos.
Jetzt haben wir das Thema Bier zu Audi sind gute Autos umgeweist.
Ich wollte keine Werbung machen.
Alle anderen Autos sind auch gute Autos,
alle restlos. Aber wenn du
an das Arbeitsklima von Audi
denkst, dann ist das schon eher so
kumpelhaft und so Bierbäuchlein
hat jeder. Das ist halt Bayern,
was will man machen?
Ja, klar. Wenn du halt
sagst, okay, wir wollen,
das verändert die Industrie, wir wollen, dass
andere Leute reinkommen,
dann musst du halt ein Klima schaffen,
dass die Leute attraktiv
genug finden, dass sie sich reintrauen.
Ach, du meinst dieses kumpelhafte
Trinken Bier zusammen ist eher unattraktiv
für andere Leute.
Für Leute, die nicht schon kumpelhaft Bier trinken,
ist das kein attraktives Umfeld.
Ah, krass.
Das eröffnet
mir ganz andere Ansichten, ehrlich gesagt.
Also ich würde gerade sagen, mir fehlt das total,
mit Kollegen mal ein bisschen trinken zu gehen.
Aber es gibt natürlich auch Kollegen, die nicht gerne
mit Bier trinken gehen, weil sie irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
weil sie nicht, oder
es geht ja nicht ums Bier trinken, aber
ist es dann vielleicht
etwas, was vielleicht Frauen von solchen
Arbeitsumfeldern fernhält oder sowas?
Oder was meinst du damit?
Also, was hast du für...
Du musst jetzt immer davon ausgehen, die Leute haben ein zu
schlechtes Bild von dir.
Und wenn du etwas organisieren willst,
dann musst du...
Du präsentierst dir immer nur das Beste.
Die Leute wissen das und ziehen davon etwas ab.
Ah ja.
Ja, immer. Also das machst du auch.
Wenn du irgendwie einen Laden siehst und sagst,
ah, wir sind der beste Pizzaladen
der Welt, dann sagst du so...
oder zweitweste Pizzalatenseite.
Genau, das machst du automatisch
überall. Das heißt, wenn du dann die Leute
siehst, die stehen im Kreis,
es sind alles Männer, es wird dieses laute
Gegröle und so, dann ist dein
erster Gedanke vermutlich nicht, ach, das sind
Programmierer, die sich nach einem super technischen
Vortrag noch so ein Entspannungsbierchen können,
sondern du denkst eher so am
Fußballplatz,
ja.
Das ist halt so Arzt.
Ein bisschen, ja. Und wenn du halt
in diesem Modus schon drin bist, dann kannst du
ja, es gibt Leute, die das machen, es gibt Leute, die das nicht machen,
ich stelle mich mal dazu, ich habe da keine Berührungsängste.
Wenn das nicht der Fall ist, dann wirkt das halt so wie dieses Umfeld
und da gehen Leute halt nicht hinein.
Ist ein Vorurteil, klar, aber wenn du etwas der Öffentlichkeit mitteilen willst,
dann bist du ja dafür verantwortlich, dass das möglichst richtig ankommt.
Das heißt, du meinst, wenn das so sehr wirkt wie die Leute, die da sind,
sind eh schon alle Buddies untereinander, dann könnte das
sogar eher ein Nachteil sein, wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel
neue Mitarbeiter gewinnen willst oder sowas.
Genau, und darum haben wir auch
gesagt, wir machen diese Intros, wo wir
explizit das anschreiben, mit
Frauen ausgeschrieben, sind
willkommen, und wir erklären es gerne
für Einsteigerinnen und Einsteiger,
also wirklich
ganz lang, möglichst zugänglich,
und dann haben wir auch gesagt, du kannst jederzeit
gehen, du kannst auch zu spät
dazukommen, also haben wir
alles explizit gemacht. Wir haben diese
Vorträge auch
immer Deutsch und Englisch ausgeschrieben.
Das ist super gut darauf hinzuweisen, dass man
nicht von Anfang an da sein
muss oder dass man nicht bis zum Schluss bleiben
muss, wenn man sich das bloß angucken will.
Das ist auch wichtig. Manche Leute, könnte ich mir vorstellen,
kommen auch nicht, weil sie denken,
wenn ich dann gehe, ist es unhöflich oder
sowas oder wenn ich zu spät komme, dann brauche
ich auch gar nicht mehr kommen oder sowas.
Das stimmt, das ist alles nicht explizit irgendwie.
Oder das ist alles
nicht intuitiv, dass das
dass es aber eigentlich okay ist.
Und wenn du dann deine Einführungssession
durch hast, dann sagst du
nochmal an der Stelle,
liebe Leute, das sind so die
Regeln, hinten ist
Saft und Wasser, ihr könnt jetzt auch gerne
nach Hause, wenn ihr los müsst,
wir stellen jetzt hier die Laptops auf,
Strom kommt gleich,
halt einfach das Setting so ein bisschen
moderieren
und die, ja, das entspannt
dann auch, man kann sagen, wir machen in 5 Minuten
Kurz Pinkelpause, das Klo ist da und dort.
Genau, spürt man die Pausenmusik ab.
Genau.
Das, was du mit Streams halt mit diesen Einblendungen machst,
das musst du in echt halt auch machen,
weil es gibt keine Vortragskultur.
Oder stell dir einen Open Air vor.
Du hast einen Open Air Abend, das spielen zehn Bands.
Da kommt ja auch immer wieder mal einer
und macht Stimmung.
Dann schickt einer die Leute zum Bierstand und zum Burschtstand.
Brauchst du einen MC.
Ja, genau.
Aber ich glaube, woran wir gerade kollektiv gedacht haben,
ist das hier.
Das hier, ja.
Die gute Kongresspausenmusik.
Die gute Kongresspausenmusik,
die im vollen Namen,
ich vergesse es immer,
Machine Lullaby heißt.
Fear of Ghosts.
heißt doch das Lied. Der Interpret heißt Fear of Ghosts.
Ah, ist das Interpret?
Machine Lullaby 1.
Ach, das vermisst ich auch.
Wir reden zu viel über
die gute alte Zeit in diesem Podcast.
Ist das so ein Corona-Ding eigentlich?
Natürlich trauern wir gerade der alten Welt
hinterher, logisch.
Während zwei Jahren leben wir anders als je zuvor.
Wir leben erst seit einem Jahr so.
Ja, je nachdem.
Das kommt aber immer länger vor, ne?
Das ist recht.
Es ist aber schon das zweite Jahr, also es ist ja schon über ein Jahr.
Danke erstmal Stefan für deinen Einblick.
Sonst können wir einfach das CRM kurz ansprechen und dann kannst du das abschließen.
Ja, genau.
Also wir trauern viel zu sehr den alten Zeiten nach.
Sprich doch mal das CRM an.
Ich versuche da den Lübber anzuschneiden.
Okay.
Was ist so geil ist das CRM?
Das Crew Resource Management.
Vorhin gesprochen, genau.
Okay, sorry.
Ja.
Kein Problem.
Also ganz kurz, wenn wir jetzt den Rahmen definiert haben, wie wir uns verhalten wollen,
was für Snacks wir haben oder keine Snacks, die Zeiten kommuniziert sind und die Leute da sind und alles super ist,
irgendwann wird es ein bisschen viel und dann müssen wir vielleicht uns auch eingestehen,
dass wir selber nicht die Zeit haben, das auf die bestmögliche Art zu machen.
Und dann parallelisieren wir uns.
Wir suchen uns Freunde, die uns helfen, das mitzumachen.
Und was ich sehr spannend finde, es gibt eine Industrie,
die das sehr tief drin hat inzwischen.
Das sind die Flieger, also die Piloten.
Und die haben CRM, das Crew Resource Management.
Und das hilft ihnen bei kritischen Phasen.
Warum gerade Piloten?
Weil die über die Jahrzehnte von einer Industrie, wo du gesagt hast,
ja, ich steige jetzt in den Flieger, ich bete zu Gott, auch wenn ich nicht daran glaube,
und ich habe meinen Abschied geregelt.
Das hat sich komplett geändert.
Es gab furchtbare Unfälle am Anfang.
Zu heute fliegst du für zum Teil massiv subventioniert 20 Euro irgendwo hin.
Du machst dir keine Gedanken darüber, wie das Wetter ist, ob irgendwie das deine Sicherheit gefährdet.
Also fliegen ist ja sicherer als Autofahren oder Radfahren, noch schlimmer.
Und wie kam das?
Und das kam halt, weil die ihre Unfälle akribisch aufgearbeitet haben und dann zum einen Technologie entwickelt haben,
dass sie zum Beispiel Wetterradars eingebaut haben
und Karten mitführen und, und, und.
Und dann haben sie auch Checklisten gemacht.
Und das sollten wir uns für große Projekte auch vornehmen.
Also wenn du dir sagst, wir machen jetzt eine Serie
zum Thema Embedded Rust zum Beispiel,
dann hilft es, sich am Anfang zu überlegen,
wie gehe ich da rein, gibt es verschiedene Varianten,
wie viele Teile mache ich das?
Und dann machst du dir eine Checkliste für dich selbst
und sagst, okay, in diesen Zeitabständen muss ich zum Beispiel Zusagen haben von Rednerinnen,
die dann ein Thema vorstellen.
Und dann hältst du das durch.
Und was das mit der Crew zu tun hat, ist dann, wenn ihr zu dritt oder zu viert seid,
dann sagst du, okay, ich kümmere mich um das, das ist meine Verantwortung.
Die anderen können auch noch mitarbeiten, aber wenn es Fehler gibt,
dann geht es nicht zuerst mal mit dem Finger, du hast,
Sondern man sagt, okay, was ist passiert?
Wie machen wir weiter?
Wie kriegen wir das wieder zusammen?
Und bei der Fliegerei gibt es
Checklisten für alles.
Achso, das ist quasi ein Projektmanagement-Tool.
Es ist auch
ein Umgangston. Also du schaffst
dann ein Arbeitsklima,
das mit...
Beschreib doch mal ganz kurz CRM
irgendwie in zwei Sätzen.
Also wenn ich es
richtig verstanden habe, geht es darum,
wenn etwas schief geht
und nach Murphy geht irgendwann immer etwas schief,
dass du dann nicht den Schuldigen suchst,
sondern dass du auch aus der zweiten Reihe das sagen kannst,
ohne dass die Person, die das vielleicht nicht bemerkt hat,
aber hätte bemerken sollen, sich beleidigt fühlt.
Also ein Beispiel von den Fliegern,
es gibt ja meistens den erfahreneren und den weniger erfahrenen Piloten
und wenn dann noch kulturelle, gefühlte Machtverhältnisse dazukommen,
zum Beispiel der sehr erfahrene alte Mann und diese sehr junge, frisch von der Flugschule Pilotin,
dann ist mit dem CRM auch das Training drin, dass die junge Unerfahrene sagen kann,
hey, schau mal, das ist komisch und dass er dann nicht sagt,
oh, hast du keine Ahnung, das machen wir schon immer so,
sondern dass er dann sagt so, aha, okay.
Klassischer didaktischer Fehler.
Genau, aber halt nicht auf diese Lehrer-Schüler-Rollen ausgerichtet,
sondern auf ein Team, dass du sagst,
es gibt Leute, die haben mehr Erfahrung als andere,
aber wir machen alle Fehler
und darum ist es okay,
wenn unerfahrene Leute uns dumme Fragen stellen.
Also es gibt ja diesen Unterschied zwischen Leuten,
die dir konstruktiv etwas sagen sollen,
auch wenn es vielleicht doof rüberkommt und trollen.
Das ist auch dieses Meme von den Computer-Nerds,
dass die das genau falsch machen, oder?
dass du, wenn du irgendwie in eine neue Sprache, in eine Online-Community, in irgendein Forum,
gerade der Begriff Forum ist mit sowas ja vorbelastet, wo du reinkommst und dich mit den Experten unterhältst.
Gerade selbst, besonders in so Linux wahrscheinlich, ist so genau dieses Toxische,
wo die alten Neckbeards dann die Unerfahrenen, die vielleicht auch erstmal Fehler machen,
so richtig zur Schnecke machen auf so eine Art und Weise.
Das habe ich lange angenommen. Das ist wahrscheinlich so in der Technologiebranche das Normale, dass die Leute so miteinander reden.
Ich glaube nicht mehr zumindest. Also es war mal mehr Vorurteil als es aktuell ist.
Natürlich gibt es solche Menschen, die gab es schon immer, die würden es immer geben.
Aber ich persönlich sehe sowas zumindest schon sehr lange nicht mehr, dass auf so eine Art und Weise untereinander gesprochen wird.
Das ist wahrscheinlich so ein kulturelles Ding, das muss sich erstmal rauswachsen quasi, wenn es genügend Leute anders machen, dann geht es weg.
Ja, aber es gibt so Ecken, wo das immer noch ist. Also OpenMPI habe ich vor ein paar Jahren angeschaut und dann habe ich so eine Frage gestellt auf Stack Overflow, habe mir so extra einen Account gemacht auf der Plattform und so, ja, ich habe das versucht, ich habe diesen Beispielcode genommen und er lief nicht und es kam diese komische Fehlermeldung.
und die einzigen drei Kommentare waren irgendwie so
ein kommentarloser Link auf eine Man-Page,
ein Schau im Handbuch nach oder Du hast das falsch gemacht.
Ja, genau.
Du hast es falsch gemacht, das ist auch schön.
Ja, ich meine, dass ich es falsch gemacht habe, weiß ich auch.
Aber das hat mir nichts genutzt.
Es gibt so Leute, die sind da manchmal sehr rücksichtslos
oder sehr un...
Unempathisch.
Nicht unempathisch, aber
unvergebend.
Ah, okay.
So vergebungslos, wenn du so Anfängerfehler machst.
Hast du als Noob eh nicht in dem Projekt verloren.
Also wenn du zu dumm bist,
das Beispiel zu starten.
Ich erwarte das von dir oder sowas.
Ja.
Oder ein anderes Beispiel.
Irgendwelche Open Source-Projekte,
die kein Git-Repo zur Verfügung
stellen. Wenn du da
auf der Mailing-Liste fragst,
so, hey, habt ihr auch
ein Git-Repo? Ja, ist
intern. Ja, kann man sich das
anschauen? Nein, lad
dir die Target-Set runter von
der Website. Von dem Code.
Ja, genau. Ist halt nicht so
geil. Das ist halt vorsinnfluglich, oder?
Ja. Gibt es da noch
viele von, die sowas machen?
Nicht viele, aber ein paar
Kritische gibt es schon, so im DNS-Bereich.
Und so,
der eine Resolver
da war dann halt so, ja, ist Open Source
und lacht dir halt
die Zips runter.
Also das ist halt so Open Source zum,
du kannst es mal kurz angucken,
wenn du willst, aber es ist halt nichts, was einladen ist
zu mitarbeiten. Das hatten wir ja schon mal.
Es gibt das Google-Modell, wir werfen
Code über den Zaun
und es gibt das Contribution-Modell von wegen
hier schickt uns eure Patches und Pull-Requests
und Merge-Requests und was auch immer.
Und dann gibt es das Luca-Modell.
Das was?
Wir machen es Open-Source, weil wir gepressured werden
und dann stellen wir uns unter eine Open-Source-Lizenz,
weil wir festgestellt haben,
dass wir eigentlich eine andere Open-Source-Lizenz verletzt haben.
Und dann entwickeln wir uns doch wieder privat weiter.
Die Luca-App meinte Hendrik gerade.
Ah, die Luca-App.
Oder das Schweizer Post-Cycle-Modell fürs E-Voting.
Open Source per Gesetz,
aber veröffentlicht wird nur in so Häppchen und Blog-Posts.
Aber auch nicht schlecht.
Naja, es gibt ja so Open Source-Projekte,
diese Google-Projekte,
die einmal im Monat oder sowas auf GitHub hochgeladen werden
und dann hast du immer ein Commit pro Monat oder so,
wo sich dann irgendwie 35.000 Dateien auf einmal ändern.
Ja, ist nicht schön, aber stell dir vor, du hast
zentrale Infrastruktur von deinem Land
und die wird schon produktiv eingesetzt
und du weißt nicht, wie sie funktioniert
und die Häppchen, die sie dir zeigen,
sind eher besorgniserregend als sonst was.
So ein Motto, hätte ich es mir lieber nicht angeguckt.
Ja, ja, ja.
Das wollte ich gar nicht wissen.
So ein bisschen der Sausage-Effekt,
dass du die Software gerne nutzt,
aber sobald du weißt, wie sie gemacht wird,
würde ich lieber nicht mehr anfassen.
Der Sausage-Effekt.
so ein bisschen wie Akronomisier gemacht.
Du meinst, du hörst den Podcast gerne,
bis du einmal Gast warst und dann nicht mehr.
Du weißt, wie hier da geschnitten wird.
Aber vielleicht könnt ihr noch die zwei Tipps machen,
die ich noch hätte.
Das eine ist vor dem Machen.
Lass uns das doch mal rephrasen als
wir nähern uns langsam
dem zeitlichen Limit
und listen noch unsere Pics auf.
und du könntest diese Tipps als Picks
oder falls du noch extra Picks hast, dann gerne auch
aufzählen.
Ja,
tun wir das.
Schieß mal los.
Schieß dich los, okay.
Trommel.
Das war von mir
der höllprigste Übergang ever.
Also,
wenn Events
durch sind oder abgesagt
wurden, dann
kurzes Postmorte machen.
Das fand ich am Anfang
total mühsam,
aber es hilft schon, wenn du
irgendwie drei, vier Chat-Nachrichten hast.
Also besser ist natürlich etwas größeres.
Warst du das dann öffentlich oder innerhalb
vom Team? Nein,
in keinem Fall öffentlich. Das ist das andere.
Team-Essen
oder Feier oder irgendwas,
Team-Treffen ohne Kameras, ohne Aufzeichnung.
Dass man sich wirklich einfach entspannt
ausprobieren kann.
vielleicht auch gar nichts Formales.
Vielleicht sagt man einfach, ja, wir sitzen uns da
in den Hackerspace rein und
quatschen mit den Leuten
und organisieren vielleicht noch was, vielleicht auch
nicht.
Also das hört man sich irgendwo...
Ansonsten ist Postmortem ja generell
auch eine gute Idee bei allen möglichen Sachen.
Ich meine, du meinst, du willst es eher nicht öffentlich machen,
das ist ja völlig okay, obwohl es wahrscheinlich
auch hilfreich wäre, so manche Informationen
da zu veröffentlichen, solange es halt Relevanz hat.
In manchen Firmen gibt es
richtige Postmortem-Mailing-Listen.
Das ist auch clever. Dann kriegst du Postmortems
für Bugs in Software, von der du gar nicht
wusstest, dass deine Firma die herstellt.
Also ich meine, man kann viel
aus sowas lernen. Man hat ja auch diesen Push, dass man
halt versucht, in der Wissenschaft auch
Paper zu veröffentlichen, die halt nicht das
gewünschte Resultat entdeckt haben.
Die sind auch viel zu selten gemacht, gerade in der Wissenschaft.
Eben, genau. Das ist halt ein Problem, wenn du halt,
das ist auch eine Form von Survivorship Bias,
wenn du halt nur die guten Seiten
publischst, dann findest du halt auch viele Sachen
eben nicht, die halt widerlegt wurden.
Das heißt, glaube ich, hier
Learn from my fail, oder?
Ist das schon...
Gibt es da nicht sogar eine Überschrift?
Ach nee, das waren mal so Katzenbilder.
Krass.
Ja, Postmortem ist definitiv
ein ausgezeichneter Tipp
auch für andere Projekte, dass man
sich einfach hinterher mal drüber unterhält und es wird auch zu selten gemacht.
Was ist denn jetzt da schiefgegangen?
Und das muss man aber möglichst
ohne Blame hinkriegen, auf jeden Fall.
Unbedingt, ja.
Also wenn Leute schon nicht mit Feedback umgehen können, dann würde ich das sehr kurz halten.
Und es ist auch ein Lernprozess.
Das andere Bild, das ich vielleicht verliebt habe, war, dass wenn die Leute ein bisschen,
wie sagt man, es gibt ein neues Wort dafür, neuroatypisch sind, so ADHS und so,
Die Leute finden dann Dinge sehr spannend
und können das super organisieren,
muss man aber dann auch nicht enttäuscht sein,
wenn diese Leute einen Monat später
komplett andere Interessen haben.
Das habe ich auch schon erwähnt.
Das ist auch Blame-Fry.
Also auch wenn es funktioniert hat
und alles super war und die Leute einfach kein Interesse mehr haben,
war gut.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
So, jetzt habe ich sehr viel geredet.
Ja, ich habe noch einen ganz klassischen Pick.
es zeigt keinen GitHub-Stern, sondern eine Webseite,
über die ich gestern gestolpert bin.
Ich glaube, die ist auch noch relativ frisch. Die heißt sofort-impfen.de.
Wenn wir schon wieder
zum Corona-Thema...
Die hatte irgendwer, da habe ich Werbung für gesehen.
Echt?
Ja.
Ich weiß auch nicht, aus welchen Kreisen die genau kommen, aber die Idee gefällt mir sehr,
dass du dich da halt auf die Mailing-Liste setzt mit deiner Postleitzahl
und Impfangebote
von Ärzten aus deiner Umgebung.
Ich sehe, das wäre bei einer Form...
Willige Ärzte aus deiner Impfgebung impfen jetzt.
Mir kam das ein bisschen fishy vor,
weil es halt so ähnlich wie Luca ist,
irgendwie eine Firma, die sagt,
komm, wir machen jetzt was, wo alle aufspringen müssen.
Nee, solange es hat funktioniert
und ich meine Impfung darüber kriege,
ich meine, ich gebe denen bloß meine E-Mail-Adresse und meine Postleitzahl
und wenn da halt ein Arzt mich dann anschreibt,
dann haben die ja auch nichts mehr davon.
Du zahlst ja nichts dafür, du gibst ja keine anderen Datenpreise oder so.
Ist das so, ja?
Das ist wirklich bloß...
Was ist denn der Geschäftsmodell?
Es gibt kein Geschäftsmodell.
das Geschäftsmodell, das ist Impfungen verteilen.
Und es geht halt nicht über die,
sondern die geben halt wirklich bloß dann
eine Plattform.
Und das finde ich sehr sympathisch und ich hoffe
darüber irgendwann mal meine Impfung zu kommen.
Ich will die Impfung endlich haben.
Krass, ja cool,
vielen Dank. Habe ich einen Pick überhaupt?
Ich glaube, ich habe dieses Mal keinen Pick.
Die letzte Sendung war gerade erst
sehr lange her.
Habe ich irgendwas,
was ich neulich schon mal gestartet habe?
Nee.
Es gibt noch den Pick
für das 15. Mai,
das Jubiläum von Rust.
Das ist ja
schon dieses Wochenende.
Sechs Jahre Rust.
Holy shit.
Dann können wir uns bald
mit sechs Jahren Rust-Erfahrung
bewerben.
Das sind ja überall acht oder zehn Jahre schon gefragt.
Ja, das hatte, glaube ich, Steve Klepnik
am Anfang einen Witz gemacht, als es rauskam
mit 1-0, ist jetzt der Zeitpunkt für Firmen
irgendwie fünf Jahre Rest-Empfeierung
vorauszusetzen.
Weißt du, ob da irgendwas geplant ist?
Wir hatten mal was vor,
aber dann im Sumpf
vom zweiten, dritten Lockdown habe ich dann
nichts mehr gehört.
Das heißt, wir machen dann einfach ein großes
Jitsi auf mit der
europäischen Community und
trinken gemeinsam jeder in seinem Land oder seiner
Stadt ein Bierchen oder sowas.
Das ist ja schon dieses Wochenende.
Ich glaube, das schaffen wir nicht mehr.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich die Folge bis dahin...
Zum Hören der Folge ist wahrscheinlich schon danach.
Ach, das war ja letztes Wochenende.
Ja, cool.
Vielleicht kommt die Folge
dann am Samstag raus.
Ich habe noch einen Tipp.
Ich habe noch einen Pick.
Heute ist
sechs Jahre Rust-Jubiläum.
Ich schneide jetzt einfach deinen ganzen Text weg.
Es ist so, als ob ich mir das ausgedacht hätte.
Sehr schön.
Ich glaube, an dieser Stelle können wir jetzt auch langsam den Bogen
spannen.
Ich glaube, an dieser Stelle können wir auch den Bogen langsam entspannen,
bevor sich noch jemand wehtut.
Vielen lieben Dank, Stefan.
Es hat sehr viel Spaß gemacht wieder mit dir.
Ja, danke fürs dabei sein.
Danke, dass du kommen durfte.
Auf jeden Fall. Vielen Dank,
dass du uns ein bisschen Einblicke in deine
Meetup-Orga gegeben hast. Das hat mir auch
für vielleicht mein
Meetup, was ich eventuell nach dem,
ich will nichts versprechen, nach dem Lockdown,
nach der Pandemie wieder antrete,
Inspiration. Zumindest du hast
auch mir damit Inspiration gegeben, vielleicht mein
Meetup mal wieder aufzuwecken.
Ich habe sehr viel Lust, Meetups zu besuchen.
Besuchen ist immer schön.
Besuchen ist immer ganz toll.
In diesem Sinne,
Vielleicht sehen wir euch, Liebhörer,
irgendwann mal auf einem Meetup in irgendeiner Stadt
oder online.
Bleibt auf jeden Fall gesund.
Vielen lieben Dank, Stefan.
Und möchtest du mal den Countdown machen?
Okay, das kann ich machen.
Dann kann ich noch etwas ganz Schamloseres machen.
Wenn ihr wollt,
dass unsere beiden
Gastgeber bei euch
in eurem Meetup auftauchen,
dann ladet sie ein und können sie
nämlich die Speaker-Erfahrung machen
und den nächsten Podcast in eurem
Podcast, dann hört ihr ihn.
5, 4, 3,
2, 1.